at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
hey everybody what's going on yep uh
yeah that was our new [ __ ] gotta I
thought Jenny knocked it out of the park
I think it's a good I think I just
finished that today like this afternoon
actually I was kind of rushing yeah I
thought it came out pretty good like you
know I'm getting a little bit better at
uh video editing I'm still not really
that great at it but she showed she
showed me earlier today and I looked at
it oh no that's awesome I like that I
said don't change anything okay yeah I
thought it was good oh I heard her go
yeah
then I went down to uh I went down to
the Oasis
had a few so I've already pre-gamed a
little bit but not much
I only had three he's gonna be you know
they are they pour me double so it's
kind of like 86. he's gonna be running
around talking about ghosts and [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna ghost the [ __ ] out
it goes the [ __ ] out yeah we're doing a
fun paranormal show yeah so we don't
have to so we don't have to worry about
like yeah you know feeling bad about
like people get a murderer and stuff
[ __ ] gets Downer sometimes man I'm
trying to like make jokes about it but
it's like [ __ ] yeah you don't really
watch yeah that's what I mean
I like Paranormal and UFO for some
reason you know a lot of people the UFOs
flooded on the YouTube Market that's
true and a lot of dudes that talk about
the [ __ ] UFO stuff I don't think
they're very
good at it if you ask me there's there's
a few channels but a lot of them are
the very samey and the guys don't really
have the personality for it you know if
you ask me
but there are a few good ones
Jenny doesn't like the subject though
she's just
she thinks it's saving which it is
there's a lot yeah well the thing about
it is that like all the best cases we've
already covered right you know what I
mean and it's like the rest of it it's
just kind of like what are you gonna do
it's like somebody was in Kansas and saw
uh
you know what I mean yeah they're all
just kind of like that yeah
I like some of the science programs are
about it yeah talk about it now you know
like Avi Loeb he's like on Event Horizon
a lot and they're postulating what
what extraterrestrial civilizations
could be like how many different what
that's shit's real interesting too you
know
whether they're technological or not
and what technology ends up looking like
what biology might end up looking like
because there's a bunch of different
ways it could go on a planet you know I
think that's just cool to think about
that
and what it would be like if one of them
came here I don't think they'd be
biological
I think I think [ __ ] 2001 got it
right
it'd be like that
Tom Sykes says paranormal True Crime
crossover shows of the Supreme shows my
opinion yeah to be honest I'm kind of
like sad that there's not more cases
like that where there was like a
horrible like like for example like the
Herb Baumeister case which is kind of
like the platonic ideal of it because it
was like a serial killer and like
horrible [ __ ] happened there but then it
was like haunting [ __ ] like afterward
too so it was kind of like both things
that's a good one and like I said you
don't really have that happen much no
you know yeah you could say Amityville
Horror but I think that like the
Amityville Horror haunting [ __ ] was uh I
think that one was made up yeah I think
that one was uh Market forces working I
mean I think a lot of Haunting [ __ ] is
made up but you know what I mean yeah
you know what I mean at least
and at least the Herb Baumeister one had
the
um you know it wasn't as well known I
mean everybody and their mom knows about
Amityville Horror you know what I'm
saying yeah so
uh John Gora said are you guys ever
going to review the greasy Strangler
from 2017. I've been actually wanting to
see that so we probably will get around
to it one of these days I'll have to see
I'm gonna look and see where it's
streaming at
so maybe I'll put it in a poll like this
upcoming week or something like that if
we can watch it for free yeah we finally
got on to Jenny we finally got on top of
the bills with [ __ ] the show
we're on top of it now we gotta wait
till next month so uh today we're
finally gonna get the super chats that
you guys [ __ ] gave not today what are
you talking about what are you talking
about this month right yeah end of this
month what I meant you don't know what
you're talking about I know I don't talk
mom's have been drinking this month
exactly you don't know we gotta get
these damn super chats going and [ __ ]
um I wanna we're gonna go ahead and put
out another uh
uh message that we're looking for
patrons the channel is looking for
patrons the patronage just [ __ ]
slipped over the past couple years we're
gonna try to get that up to about 600
bucks a month so we can keep this shell
going we we know we got the most
hardcore listeners on right now going
live that's the way it always is but
we're gonna we're recording this and
this is for uh y'all that can't catch us
live please if you know if you guys
could send Jenny a [ __ ] uh some
Patron money there on um what's it
called patreon you just said I was gonna
say only fans and I would say well we
don't we haven't released that video yet
thank you Grand Theft thank you very
much I like the little fireworks there I
really don't think this or are they
fireworks they're yeah I guess they're
like fireworks or snowflakes or
something they're very very small uh
Dave is here hello had a mad day you
both are my rush hour Home Entertainment
so thank you thank you very much you
know okay that's what we we try we try
to catch like people entertained we try
to keep ourselves entertained it's not
always easy
but you know yeah you're gonna be all
right you're gonna you're gonna make it
you sure yeah because you already seem
kinda no I'm good okay you weren't there
that long I mean you were only there for
like a couple of hours yeah a couple
hours which is not usually I mean I
drink three doubles a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
my God yeah Cuervo I'm not that [ __ ]
up
no and then I lay down mostly it was
when I came back I almost almost fell
asleep yeah I figured so I was kind of
like in between sleep another week so
see that wake up well you got to watch
him because it's like right before the
show started like he came in and he
brought the drinks and everything and
then like he went away and then he was
doing something and then it was like
getting closer time and closer I'm like
where the [ __ ] did he go like he didn't
come back and I didn't hear anything
yeah and then I ran to get him and I was
like uh I was afraid I was afraid you'd
like fall asleep or something I was
talking business with uh Dimitri yeah
yeah he gets he always does something
like right at the last minute and then
he gets distracted no he called me so I
got distracted it wasn't my fault yeah
called me so you're blaming somebody
else that's okay
see this people this is
damn damn I'm just teasing you yeah
she messed with me because she knows I'm
[ __ ] defenseless yeah whenever I
start drinking I get defenseless see she
starts picking she's a [ __ ] she's a
harpy she's one of those harpies from
[ __ ] hey I'll pick on you in here the
old guy's blind and the [ __ ] harpies
are coming again oh come on you're not
that healthy he's just trying to eat you
know what I mean yeah it's like that
yeah
Tom Sykes said I just watched The
Haunting TV film last night and prep for
the show and because it's a kick-ass
made for TV flick yeah I kind of feel
like we talked about because we reviewed
that movie not too long ago which movie
it was the TV movie It's called The
Haunted
um I think it's called The Haunted
um and it's about the smurl case
remember we just like we just reviewed
it like a few months ago uh yeah and we
probably talked about which one was that
they all started well I mean when when I
started talking about the occasional
probably know what I'm talking about
okay yeah but that's the thing and I
think we've talked about this moral case
a little bit before because remember
we've done a couple shows where it's
like cases of the Warrens yeah and the
Warrens that were involved in this one
so I think we talked about it a little
bit another one but that's kind of one
of the reasons why like I wanted to
cover it
um just kind of you know more in depth
or whatever but that's why I added a
couple other haunted cases on there
there two that I'm pretty sure we
haven't talked about so then that way it
wasn't just like us in case we were like
repeating information you know what I
mean yeah Tom Sykes said the San Pedro
haunting is uh almost similar to Enfield
Poltergeist case with the old dude
entity and the San Pedro uh case almost
like the Doris bitter case yeah they
both had a very Taff working on them so
we're gonna talk about that one I've
been wanting to do a show about that one
for a long time because that's like a
weird ass case Taft actually has a
pretty good reputation with with Tom
with me
um he did good work on the entity case
yeah and some of the other ones
based on things that he said you know
I've seen Poltergeist it was in my
family
based on things he's he has said
I'm very sure that he's seen the
phenomena I don't think he's faking
okay
but uh he he mentioned some things in
interviews like yeah okay he's seen it
before
so he's I wouldn't put him in the in the
case with like the Warrens you know yeah
which I think the Warren saw a few stuff
that was real but they were more into
making fake [ __ ]
yeah I kind of feel like they were like
well you know we just need to sell some
books and some lectures and [ __ ] like
that so the phenomenon is too rare you
know if exciting stuff doesn't happen
then we'll just like you know make it up
yeah the real phenomena is too rare it's
not common enough to make a damn career
off of you know
just didn't happen enough
Tom Sykes says sure you remember that
film Tom when the father was getting
raped by that fat man in a wig succubus
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah remember
it's been a while he looked uh yeah I
remember that one I remember that scene
what a hilarious scene that was yeah I
mean definitely a dude that was
definitely rape's not funny but like the
way that they kind of like did it and it
was supposed to be a ghost and it were a
demon or whatever there was a dude in a
costume if you ask me well yeah it
obviously was it's
maybe they couldn't find a woman that
would make it worse
[Laughter]
I don't know I don't know this whole and
and the thing about it too is that since
we were bringing up Doris bether she
also said that she was sexually
assaulted by
ghosties
so I guess that's like kind of a common
thing I wrote about a couple cases like
that in uh unseen hand you know what I
mean where but it's kind of it's kind of
rare really it's the small case and the
Doris bither case and I think there was
one other one but I can't remember what
it was where people said they got raped
by demonic entities
uh thank you very much Senor sticks
uh if you came across James Dean's car
pieces are you haunted no I don't think
James Dean would haunt anybody well I
don't know I don't know Dean's gone he's
not the kind of guy that would be
hanging around he had it he has better
[ __ ] to do all right you would think
yeah
Richard Brown said have you read any of
Colin Wilson's paranormal investigation
books I don't think so like that name is
familiar but I kind of feel like maybe
but it was probably like a long time ago
you know
Zach said uh I saw somewhere once
Christina Aguilera said she had sex with
a ghost and it was the best screw she
ever had really
[Laughter]
I wonder did she really say that or was
she serious or was she just [ __ ]
around I don't know I had to dig into
that
[Laughter]
Tom's like oh now I'm intrigued well
Sue sang a song that was about that from
off The Tinderbox called Swedish chill
remember that that was about [ __ ]
love romance with the damn ghost
sweet as chip it's a good song
well yeah I can see how that'd be goth
girl fantasy
I don't know about fantasy but it is
kind of nice it's like oh they just kind
of be around like what if that ghost was
hot
well what what that nose was hot I don't
know that's what that's what she was
talking about hot ghosts it's a hot
ghost yeah
like a hot Gothic ghost
that loves you
I just I don't know it would be kind of
weird because on the one hand like maybe
they would be like all ethereal and they
would just be there sometimes and not
there sometimes but then on the other
hand you would think they were probably
around all the time like watching you do
everything so you wouldn't feel like you
had any privacy in order to me there was
a whole [ __ ] movie about it called
Ghost and Mrs Muir yeah well there's
been more than one like that there's
been more than one like that great we
should probably review that yeah if you
guys haven't seen that it was from the
50s it was Black and White movie
Ghost and Mrs Muir about this woman who
moves into this house and turns out the
house was haunted by an old sea captain
who accidentally killed himself up in
the upstairs
and he was in love with her and he
watched over and it was a love story
between this ghost and this woman uh she
had kids I think
did she have kids I remember thinking I
don't remember it's been a long time
since I've seen that
and and he waits around for her to die
it's a good movie real good movie it's a
chick waiting for you to die yeah just
wait for her to die I could probably
kill you just like by pushing you down
the stairs or something like that like
it's a chick flick but it's a real good
chick flick it's a horror chick flick
well they did one uh later on I caught I
want to say it was like the 90s or the
early 2000s called Truly Madly Deeply uh
pretty sure Alan Rickman was in it
wasn't Alan Rickman in that
yeah that was kind of the same thing
where it was like a living woman like
falling in love with a ghost or they
fell in love with each other
yeah he helped her out because she
couldn't make the bills and it's just
how that happens what the ghost got a
job no
you don't remember how it happened no it
was I said it was a long time ago that I
saw it
um
she couldn't make the bills
so what the ghost started to do is to
tell her old sea captain stories and she
was writing them down and so and got him
oh okay I got you that was enough to pay
for the house
and then um
but I don't want to spoil the movie man
you make me spoil the movie but no I'm
not making you I'm not I didn't say
anything all right it's a real old movie
he decides that
the captain he just is the ghost of the
captain decides over time
that he's [ __ ] her life up that she's
got to live a normal life so he
makes her forget
see but normal lives are overrated yeah
well that kind of happens too
you just got to see the movie
that's why I always kind of bumps me out
like it was like well you need to live a
normal life I'm like [ __ ] that who the
hell was living normal life yeah well
she got [ __ ] over a normal life in the
end yeah I guess but he was waiting for
her it's just it's a good movie it's
like a that's another one we should
probably do that I'm gonna write that
down because I'll forget otherwise all
right but we should probably review it
because I haven't seen it since I was a
[ __ ] it's classic yeah I know I
haven't seen it it's like uh it's up
there with the Wizard of Oz I would say
in terms of [ __ ] epicness around that
same time oh and I also have to write
down the greasy Strangler because we got
to do that one too
I'm just I'm writing on my whiteboard
because I haven't put up my
my January calendar
so I'm just writing on my little
calendar over there like that
okay so uh there was uh something else I
wanted to like mango is going to spoil
the way it's a great film yeah yeah and
then someone's been a great score by
Bernard Herman yeah see and we were just
talking about him other day because he
did this question Rickman was in it yeah
Alan Rickman was in Truly Madly Deeply
um Rex Harrison was in [ __ ] um yeah
uh uh [ __ ] goes to Mrs Muir
that's right you all know the movie
that's a great movie yeah like it's it's
a classic like I said but I haven't seen
it since I was a kid yeah John Gore said
around Halloween the Goodwill store has
a banner saying we know creepy I think
better would be everything in our store
is haunted could apply all year
awesome they should actually probably
they should lean into that some people
like probably love it grabther said
y'all are making fun of ghosts doing it
with humans but hundreds of millions
believe a ghost impregnated a virgin
named Mary that's X that's right that's
true that's right yeah I mean that's
what they were talking about yeah pretty
much pretty much I mean it's it's a
distinction without a difference really
laughs
uh but yeah so
you sure you're all right yeah why
wouldn't I okay you just like don't seem
like all that you kind of seem like
you're out of it a little bit no just
thinking all right uh are you ready to
get into like some of these cases or you
know you want to [ __ ] about
something else we're ready to go all
right you sure okay ready to go oh you
should tell everybody that you've
finished you got all your stuff for your
uh oh that's right for your thing for
your costume I could tell
[Laughter]
I got I got everything
um for uh Band costume from the [ __ ]
that Dark Knight movie got the mask
it's pretty good there's some changes I
got to make to it I got the vest I got
the pants
I got the leather [ __ ]
forearm guard that he has
um
I got a chain I got the boots that he
wore pretty close but there's some
leather work I'd have to do I gotta add
some straps which I have everything for
that
I got all the leather tools to do it
and I got 20 milliliters of [ __ ]
strand coming so I'm gonna do that I'll
be it once I get that done that trend is
gonna [ __ ] take me to the next level
if people can put up with me for that
people meaning me yeah
I'm gonna try to do that kind of slow
we're gonna see how it goes that first
cycle I'm just gonna hide in my office
and lock you out I hate that [ __ ]
it's terrible all right
um it just makes you a [ __ ] man and it
but we're gonna see it won't be as maybe
I built up a little bit of Tolerance
towards it and uh that 20 milliliters
just two bottles
I'm gonna break that up maybe do that
over the next maybe year or maybe six
months we'll see how it goes all right
that's that's two cycles easily right
there
and um I'll pick up 15 pounds on that
probably
we'll see
and then there's good other [ __ ] I'm
gonna do
in between all that
but I'm already [ __ ] pushing Tom
Hardy [ __ ] Bane physics physique
anyway but I'm gonna look real good for
that I'm gonna do a photo shoot
you ready to do a photo shoot I have
Brian come over and do the photo shoot
if you want to
yeah I mean he'd probably take better
pictures than me yeah I mean because
he's like an actual photographer yeah
and then [ __ ] you can do all the
touch up stuff the changing backgrounds
and all that
yeah yeah we'll do something with it
it's gonna look real good and I'm trying
to get ready for
um
uh for Halloween but someone do the
whole cosplay thing muscle cosplay
yeah I don't know when I'm gonna get
started on mine but because it's gonna
be ready mine's gonna be right well I
mean we got a long time but now the the
store-bought [ __ ] that I got
I'm gonna change some of it because
it's good but it's not as good as I want
it to be it's not totally accurate
the colors don't really lend it
yeah it's I'm going to age the suit so
it actually looks like it's been worn
you know and kind of roughed up and like
I did in the movie it's gonna look real
good it's gonna look good
I'm probably gonna add a radio to it a
throat mic
because that really should have been
there
um that would look good also
because I already have that we'll see
murder Hornet said I was a chef at over
100 year old Hotel restaurant that was
supposedly haunted by a sea captain but
never seen anything yeah I mean I've
lived in a couple of houses that other
people said were haunted like my
grandfather's house which is gone now I
got torn down but my um mom and all her
siblings grew up there and they always
said it was like super haunted they
heard people walking around on the roof
they had their blankets torn off like
all kind of stuff like that and I lived
there for a long time and I never heard
or saw anything even I wanted to like I
kept waiting for like something creepy
to happen but it's like the house didn't
even creep me out it was actually a
really cool house I thought I was kind
of sad when they tore it down Tom Sykes
said the made 4 TV ghost filmed the
haunting at Seacliff Inn starring Ali
Sheedy is pretty decent film yeah I've
seen that uh that is actually very
decent and the 1996 made for TV ghost
filmed The Uninvited starring Beau
Bridges I feel like I've probably seen
that one too but I don't remember that
much about it actually those are two
more that I should write down because
I specif I do remember haunting at
Seacliff and being good because I think
I saw that not too long ago but so I'm
gonna write those two down and haunting
at Sea Cliff and
yeah
see Cliff you want you want to talk
while I'm around no no no there's no
reason nothing I can talk about
I say I'm not here to entertain these
people yeah you were I am yeah I was
looking at Pookie look at Pookie look
over your shoulder
I can't see because my wig's in the way
oh my God I was laying on her back
you look like you look like a [ __ ]
dude she looks like a little gummy bear
she's in gummy bear position
[Laughter]
you need to sit lady like you're not
ladylike at all that's okay that's what
that's what I like about it yeah I'm not
really liking it
yeah she's not a prissy at all she's
just kind of like you know what I mean
she's like a total tomboy sometimes she
gets prissy though she folds her hair
froze her arms up like that puts her
hand on her you know puts her [ __ ]
chin on her [ __ ] Paws yeah you're
seeing her do that yeah
you try to get prissy on a [ __ ]
too I've seen him every now I've seen
you yeah but usually she just kind of
like she plays around he likes plays
around her back like what yeah what are
you looking at
uh have you seen ghost watch yes I
actually did a discussion of it on my
scare Salon Channel not too long ago but
yeah I've seen it uh John Gore said the
other Uninvited is a mutant cat film
with clue gulager
I don't think I see that one so it's
hilarious uh look up Gibson in
Apalachicola Florida and then everyone's
amazed that Tom's being quiet uh no like
what I just said to talk when I was
writing
um murder Hornet said you have to look
at messenger please
so he went to go get ice this like
see Florida you guys you put you fill
the cup up with ice and then like 10
minutes later in the [ __ ] [ __ ] is all
melted
yeah so um
yeah ghost watch is really really good
and I feel like more people should see
it it's kind of like it's not really
found footage it's like a mockumentary
or like a fake
live show
that was in the UK I'm gonna turn the
fan off uh oh Pookie's gonna get mad I'm
not worried about pookie Pokey fans on
fans on pookie no
look it's gonna rattle
she's like I don't she sees it I don't
like it thank you Jeffy art
oh my God I love that little animation
it's like a little
it's like a little fruit with feet and
pom-poms
how do you see it let's see that's cute
as [ __ ]
so happy
all right so are we ready to talk about
like some Demon rape band rape men
rating Ben rape Ben rapey
I mean I'm gonna sit here and be drunk
you better not fall asleep
no she's trying to set me up for failure
already
is that what I did
I'm good man okay okay
you're just I don't know I'm just kind
of worried about it no all right you're
worried too much well that's kind of my
deal you know how long have you know me
that's just what I'm like I can't help
out 11 years 12 years
I can't help it I tell myself the same
thing every day like quit worrying about
[ __ ] but it's like it doesn't work it
doesn't work you know what I mean the
only thing the only thing that would
like probably do is if I was medicated
and I don't want to do that
yeah so I just got to deal with it worry
too much I know that's what I mean I
know but I can't do anything about it
that's just the way I'm sorry sorry
uh all right so let's talk about the
[ __ ] smirls
uh you know the well the demons were
[ __ ] the swirls that's for sure
are they still around ones that had that
were living in the in the in the uh in
the duplex
yeah but it was also a a
[ __ ] Funeral Home wouldn't it now I
was thinking of the snack the snatakers
yeah we talked it sounds real familiar I
know these guys as soon as you start
talking about I'll remember I remember
who it is yeah yeah I remember
so okay so the mom and dad are Jack and
Janet smirl uh they're both Catholics
hence the involvement of the Warrens
later on spoiler alert
so they were originally living in Wilkes
bar Pennsylvania
but I guess in 1972 there was a
hurricane Hurricane Agnes and I don't
know if it [ __ ] up their house or
[ __ ] up the town or something like
that so they ended up moving to a place
called West pittson in Pennsylvania
so I guess Jack had been in the Navy uh
and he was a his job was he was a
Neuropsychiatric technician so I guess
if you went in because I had I looked at
I had to look that up I'm like I kind of
have idea what that is but what exactly
is that it's a dude that puts those
shock electrodes on your head that's
what I was saying like that's the
picture that comes up like when it's
like it's like a woman putting electrons
on somebody's head yeah that's what yeah
so that's what that's what you do
so when they moved uh in 1972 they had
two daughters whose names were Dawn and
Heather
now the house that they moved to was
actually half of a duplex like I said so
the other half was um that was where
Jack's parents John and Mary lived so I
don't know if they'd lived there before
if they all moved together I thought
they already lived there and they're
just like hey we have another half of a
duplex one which is moving there
so if they move in there everything
seems fine at first like Jack got
promoted um you know he was coaching his
daughter softball team all that kind of
stuff Janet got pregnant again you know
she was volunteering at the school and
all this other kind of stuff
so they had uh twin girls not too long
after moving and the little girls names
were Shannon and Karen
now this house is on Chase Street it's
pretty famous like so you can find it
so they lived there for a year and a
half with nothing
untoward happening
but in January of 1974 little stuff
little paranormal things started
happening
uh one of the first things that happened
was like a weird uh You're gonna laugh
at this I did a weird stain appeared on
the brand new carpet that no one could
explain
right yeah okay
so there was that couldn't have been
that some kid dropped the [ __ ] didn't
want to fess up the see that's kind of
my suspicion because that's not the
first thing that I would jump to like if
a mysterious stain appeared on the
carpet I'd be like
um
somebody one of the pets peed on it or
somebody dropped something it was like
wasn't me you know what I mean that
would have some kind of [ __ ] session
yes who's getting it on
get the carpet shampooer
yeah do they not have a perfect chamber
that would have been really weird if
they had like a weird stain and like
they they brought out the Electrolux in
it yeah it didn't like fix it it just
stayed there yeah if y'all don't have a
carpet shampoo or from Electrolux get
that [ __ ] I got one Tom has an old
school one he was so proud of that hell
yeah but it's difficult
I used to sell them so I was going these
I know how good these are [ __ ] work
yeah he talks a lot about that vacuum
cleaner or the or the carpet shampooer
yeah oh yeah it is kind of it is nice to
have it folds up small [ __ ] shampoo
your whole [ __ ] carpet all good in
there man let's clean up all kinds of
stuff
better than vacuum cleaner use them both
together well now I'm selling this [ __ ]
again
that's how you seriously but you just
sell them shoes yeah it used to be a
door-to-door vacuum cleaner salesman no
it wasn't door-to-door well you had like
you had telemarketers that would go over
yeah it's not efficient enough to go
door to door that's old school [ __ ] yeah
but I mean in the sense that you went to
people's doors but they were already
expecting you yeah yeah I had
appointments okay
how I got in there was kind of [ __ ]
sideways though there's no way I could
lose money because I had [ __ ] already
been hired to [ __ ] shampoo those
carpets yeah so that was how I got in
the house then once you're in there you
can start talking to me selling those
machines if they don't buy that machines
okay they're gonna [ __ ] give you the
money to shampoo that carpet yeah and
I'd [ __ ] make 200 bucks a [ __ ] pop
get a couple of them a day I was making
big money yeah yeah
a lot of it under the table but this is
that what to worry about that well you
already just said it to everybody a long
time ago yeah yeah so I can't prove
anything they're not going to come after
they can't prove it after all this time
yeah
granther said my house must be haunted
then because weird stains show up daily
not to buy a 9 and 11 year old whatever
cause such a thing yeah see that's kind
of what I was expecting yeah
so um
the so after that they also had kind of
like your your standard like kind of
rapping and scratching noises uh Behind
the Walls toilets start flashing by
themselves yeah so there's that that's
pretty common
uh drawers open and closing on their own
uh rocking chairs kind of like rocking
back and forth with nobody in them again
very very common you see that a lot
um they said also that these weird like
scratch marks started appearing on the
bathtub the sink and the bathroom walls
yeah and that the water pipes leaked all
the time even when they even after
they'd been repaired like a bunch of
times like they'd have a plumber and
come and fix it and then like it would
start leaking again like you know what
I'm gonna say it's all starting to sound
like typical Poltergeist [ __ ] well
yeah that's what I said this is this is
all like really really common [ __ ] real
common reported phenomenon yeah I mean
the wrapping the scratching the toilet's
flushing yeah things that don't seem
right you fix something it doesn't
really fix drips leaks [ __ ] like that
anything that's unexplained and a
nuisance and he kind of unexplained
nuisance that
sometimes Poltergeist especially if it's
all happening at the same time
like we just had leaky leaky [ __ ] this
season you wouldn't never think
Poltergeist but if you're having
scratches and knocks and wraps and all
this leaky [ __ ] happens then you go
there's something wrong here
it's like this Poltergeist is trying to
like Drive Me Crazy by doing all these
little Bitties it's a little bit
annoying things yeah things keep [ __ ]
misappearing disappearing and then you
find them in the middle of the room
sitting there waiting for you all
stacked up in a pattern or something you
know it's Poltergeist
speaking of which
one of my little canisters of coffee
that I hadn't opened yet yeah pretty
sure that disappeared did it
it was underneath that sink over there
yeah because I had two of them I bought
a pack of three I drank one of them and
then I just opened the second one yeah
and then I still have the third one
underneath but I went under there today
like to get something and it wasn't
there and I was like where did the third
one go I didn't take it it's around here
and then I was thinking well Pookie like
climbs around down there but there's no
way she would have been able to move
that because I looked all around I was
like maybe she yeah and I was like maybe
she knocked it behind something but I
can't find it so it's like I have no
[ __ ] idea where it will turn up
eventually
well I hope so yeah that was just like
really really strange I was like looking
in there and go where the [ __ ] did that
go then I thought Poltergeist moving my
[ __ ] coffee machine we'll see or put
what what's the matter she's [ __ ]
yelling and runs in yeah we're talking
about you
she's like I didn't do it yeah she
probably heard her name well yeah well
she was [ __ ] around in the cabinet
last night that's why I thought yeah but
I did but I couldn't find it and it's
too big it's not like you know a tiny
thing that you could lose it was it's
big it's like a big canister so I don't
think she could have like hidden it or
nothing
there's messages there
um yeah uh another good Pennsylvania
haunting would have been the Deanna
Simpson case which is covered by news
crew while activity happened on camera
proving the home was haunted the videos
on YouTube yeah we'll have to like look
that up I'll have to look that up
kinky ghost leaving food stains
Poulter guys don't drink coffee how do
you know I mean we don't know they steal
[ __ ] though a splash ghost is stealing
Jenny's coffee
I mean I have another can but it's just
like I've I bought a three pack
it was cinnamon hazelnut I had a three
pack of cans and I drank one can because
I just threw it away like a couple days
ago then I just opened the second can
yesterday and the third one was still
under there but now it's gone so
I don't know you did it
you did it no I didn't do it yeah you
did you're you're Poltergeist
so yeah so where was I okay so leaky
pipes then you got disembodied footsteps
and um sometimes you had a radio that
wasn't plugged in that would kind of
like come on every now and then like
you'd hear static or music on it
something like that
um also one of their TVs caught fire uh
at one stage
so uh then after that like it was that
kind of stuff like to start with and
then it started getting like worse where
it was starting to do like the whole you
know uh really really bad like vile
smells like it smelled like rotten meat
you know what I mean like that kind of
stuff
and Jack also started saying that
invisible hands would like start
caressing him at times so I was like
okay so we're we're leading up to
we're leading up to the to the demon
Reef that happens like later on
so apparently this these disturbances
went on for like about a year
and after that Jack's parents who
remember lived in the other half of the
duplex they also started reporting some
activity as well and I guess they had
lived there for longer so I guess this
was kind of strange
so they first started saying like that
there were like weird cold spots in
their house and they kept hearing a
voice that was
what are what are you doing trying to
get in the goddamn covered get out of
there
okay
it's like I just keep hearing all these
noises over there it's like really
distracting
um yeah so should they keep hearing they
keep hearing these voices that are like
swearing and screaming at each other and
all this other stuff and it sounds like
it's coming from Jack and Janet's side
of the house like they were arguing
and you know they'd be like what the
[ __ ] like why were you guys screaming
like we could hear you through the wall
and they're like dude we weren't even
home so there was that kind of [ __ ]
going on too
um Janet also thought that she heard her
mother-in-law like calling her name from
the other side of the duplex like she
would hear her name called like in her
mother-in-law's voice even when her
mother-in-law was at home or said yeah I
didn't call you so there was that kind
of [ __ ] they they each thought that the
other one was making noise you know what
I mean
so um a month after that like after the
parents started uh experiencing some
[ __ ] then Jack and Janet also started
having like cold spots in their house
and um Janet there and I think they put
this in the movie that they made the
movie's called The Haunted I'm pretty
sure I just came out in the 90s like the
early 90s I feel like 92 93 I can't
remember we just reviewed it not too
long ago but she was like down in the
laundry like doing laundry uh in the
basement and heard somebody like calling
her name you know what I mean now she
also said not too long after this that
she saw an apparition of like a very
shadowy figure like they didn't have a
face or anything it was just kind of
like a black shadow person and they kind
of walked through the house and like
disappeared through the kitchen wall
now Jack's mother Mary who lived in the
other side of the duplex also said that
she saw what she thought was the same
figure like appearing on the like
through the wall like on her side of the
duplex like it walked through the wall
you know what I mean so they reported
that as well
uh the oldest daughter whose name was
Dawn she also said that she'd seen kind
of these black ghostly figures like
floating around in her room like shadow
figure type things
so at this point [ __ ] starts to get
violent
um
because so I guess like one night Jack
said like he was laying there in bed
next to his wife and he heard somebody
Whispering like a young woman's voice
like whispering and then he turned to
look at his wife and he saw like this
shadowy figure like running up her leg
uh Jack and Janet both reported that
they had been levitated from their beds
on many occasions
and Janet levitated from their beds yeah
like so they were in their beds and they
lift up off the bed and they're like
what
look I gotta tell you I was in [ __ ]
one of the best Poltergeist cases I've
ever [ __ ] read about only thing
better would be [ __ ]
[ __ ] um
was it Windfield no uh what's that uh
Enfield Poltergeist
I didn't see no levitation
I'd be real [ __ ] impressed that right
there is a [ __ ]
that's quite a claim
that's quite a claim it is quite a claim
I'd like to hear some more about that
because them just claiming that made me
kind of like go what all right but I'm
gonna I'm gonna well the thing about it
if you're gonna just theoretically if
you're gonna fake a poltergeist haunting
you're gonna tell people that you had
like a haunting or something yeah I
think it would behoove you to not go too
outrageous with it you know what I mean
yeah because the second you start being
like Oh I got levitated out of bed and
flung against the wall
or you know I got raped by a ghost or
something like that then
people are gonna like not believe you as
readily just saying
it's quite a claim yeah it is it is I
mean I saw a lot of objects move
never scared the [ __ ] out of you but
levitated out of bed picked up I had
stuff thrown on me but you know that
you know and in Enfield the little girl
said somebody said they saw the little
girl levitating but she never made that
claim
yeah the person down the street saw
she's claimed that she saw the little
girl levitating out of her bed floating
up around the ceiling and she was down
the street she saw it which I don't know
how you do that
how hard is that to see somebody's into
somebody's bedroom from up the street
you know they're in the second floor
I think it was good yeah it just kind of
seems like yeah I can't really imagine
yeah it would be like hard to see and
like if my screens and [ __ ] Shades
and [ __ ]
no I mean I yeah I mean like I think
back then in in England they wouldn't
have had a screen in the window yeah but
not too poor for them damn insect
screens no I don't think they do that
that much over there because they don't
have like bugs they eat everything they
eat everything so there's no bugs there
they eat up all the bugs that was good
but uh it's just uh quite a claim you
know
uh and I make some big claims in
Mountain Poltergeist but the [ __ ]
happened we were there we saw it
but the levitation thing man that's
I want to say that's going too far but
then again I wasn't there well I could
have done that that's what that's what I
was just gonna say that like you're a
big leap you said to me on on several
occasions that it had that at the time
yeah that you said some of the [ __ ] that
it could have done well it if it wanted
to it could have done it would have done
it but it didn't right use that's weird
yeah it had enough strength and if it
wanted to it could easily have killed
you but it that's not what the motive me
and red said that we're like this thing
could easily kill you it has the
strength that's one thing that would
scared us about it
you know he didn't know what to expect
well anything that can just pick [ __ ] up
and like well and yours in particular
pushed a whole like big bunk bed against
the back of a door so it's like if it
can push something that was a couple
hundred pounds yeah then it could like
you know pick up a concrete block and
fling it at your head easy what scared
us mostly was how fast it could move an
object and how silently you just turned
around there'd be a bunch of objects
behind you and those are you know it
stacked up or something and they had
come from other parts of the house
downstairs and they didn't pass you you
know what I mean like how the [ __ ] did
that get there without passing me did it
go through the floor
or did it teleport
because it definitely wasn't moved there
by normal means
or it would have passed you coming up
the hallway type of deal you know
so that was what worried us more than
the strength it was like can it teleport
an object
because it seemed to be it seemed to be
teleporting them into there
I wonder if it could teleport a person
well what what if it could teleport an
object into you and kill you
oh [ __ ] yeah I guess that's what I was
worried about right or if it could
teleport an object above your head and
it falls and hits you that's see that's
what I was thinking but yeah if it could
teleport time I mean theoretically it
could teleport something inside your
body yeah yeah
like it's like hey I'm gonna take this
golf ball and I'm gonna teleport it
right into your like esophagus right but
it was rare for us to catch anything
moved trachea it was rare for us to
catch anything moving so we weren't
really sure what the mechanism was you
know the lowest in red saw pillows fly
off the bed and the [ __ ] sheets come
off and wrap around and she felt
something [ __ ] touch her you know up
around her leg and go up her waist and
stuff like a snake
but it was invisible couldn't see it
but that was only part of what it could
do some kind of exotic physics
it wasn't physical whatever it was some
kind of quantum [ __ ] Force
yeah
but you know forest from Star Wars it
was like that
red said that he goes but what is this
this is like the force from Star Wars
you know it just makes [ __ ] hover you
know
weird it is weird yeah yeah it was weird
so I mean whether it's true or not I
don't know I have my doubts about these
two yeah but um yeah they did say that
they were levitated from their beds and
Janet said that she got uh flung out of
bed uh a few times too
now their other daughter Shannon
um was also supposedly thrown out of her
bed and uh hurled against the wall and
one time either it was either a ceiling
fan or a light fixture like I'm not sure
maybe it was a ceiling fan that had a
light fixture in it
um kind of crashed down only inch a few
inches away from her like almost killed
her so there was that uh also they had a
German Shepherd named Simon and he got
thrown around uh as well the dog did so
you know poor poor dog
uh so the foul smells got a lot worse uh
so bad that is it raining yeah it's
raining it's raining yeah oh that's
right it says rain off and on right
there like I think I put the motorcycle
in like on my little I mean look I heard
I heard the garage door so heard it open
and closed right yeah I think so I mean
because the garage is right underneath
this office so it's like when the garage
door opens and closes it's really really
loud
so when you came back I was pretty sure
I heard it
yeah
watch out
okay
so yeah you're you're so yeah sorry
[Laughter]
ah yeah
so yeah so ever so the whole this whole
house is like stinking out like the
family is like gagging all the time also
and they also showed this in the movie
that uh the neighbors they said that
they would hear like somebody screaming
of like swearing and stuff like that
like from inside the house even when
nobody was there so it was like it
seemed like a lot of neighbors even knew
what was going on it's like oh it's the
screaming house you know what I mean so
there was that they did put that in the
movie like I said I don't know if that
was true or not I don't know how many of
the neighbors they interviewed for this
kind of [ __ ]
so at this point uh the smalls are just
kind of like okay well we don't really
know what what the [ __ ] to do
so they called up guess who the Warrens
yeah
so the Warrens show up in 1986. so this
has been going on for like several years
because the phenomena started in 1974.
so they've been living with this for 12
years I'm sure it wasn't constant you
know what I mean
12 years and it's not Poltergeist
yeah Poltergeist is usually usually a
short duration
talk about haunting
yeah Steve Maris says that some
hauntings have poltergeist-like effects
it's a
but usually Poltergeist is less than six
months
yeah that's true yeah
um so the Warrens show up in 86 and they
have a psychic with them
so
just like the Warrens usually do they
show up and they're just like well you
know how strong are you in your faith
and have you has anyone playing a Ouija
board and all that other kind of [ __ ]
um you know have you done something bad
that like invited demons into the [ __ ]
they were trying to like victim blade
did you place for me the church yeah
they're always like asking questions
like that have you taken the lord's name
in vain have you done anal you know
did you partake in sodomy yeah
yeah I let the demon inside of your body
yeah I wonder if that was one of the
questions they asked remember probably
knowing them yeah it probably was
so uh so yeah so this moral said no man
we didn't do any of that [ __ ] so uh so
get off our case I guess I mean you know
so the Warrens like go tour the house
and uh as they do they're always like
very sure of how many entities you have
like uh you have a problem with so they
said okay you got four presences in the
house four
one of them is kind of like an old like
an elderly woman who seems harmless
uh you got a young girl who is possibly
violent
uh a man who probably died in the house
either of illness or suicide or
something like that or like some violent
way and of course guess what a demon
yeah because there's always a demon
there's always a demon it's the one well
it's because [ __ ] Mr Warren is a
demonologist so there's got to be a
demon in there somewhere he's trained
fine demons like a witch hunter you said
a witch hunter loose he's gonna [ __ ]
find a witch that's his job and you're
gonna pay him yeah you know you called
me here to find witches I'm here to get
my money I'm gonna find a witch if I
can't find a witch I'm gonna make a
witch you know that's the same thing
that's how Ed was
what they started doing too I feel like
in some of the later cases was like oh
well you have all these other ghosts oh
and then by the way there's a demon too
because I kind of feel like maybe they
were cognizant of the fact that yeah
they were just coming to everybody's
housing being like it's a demon you know
so now they're just saying oh no it's to
ghost ghost goes oh yeah but there's
like a demon over here too we also have
to understand Christian
culture at the time
uh I don't know if it's still like this
today but you know me I'm a cultural
Christian of course and grew up with a
Christian type relatives in an
environment
anything paranormal was associated with
demons demonic yeah
so if you see a ghost there's a demon
somewhere
that's just the way they think of things
yeah in a normal Christian World there
shouldn't be any paranormal [ __ ] if
something paranormal that something's
wrong is that that's bad and that's
demons doing that even though it clearly
says in the New Testament that Jesus was
doing paranormal [ __ ] and other people
were casting out demons in Jesus's name
so Christianity is actually a paranormal
paranormal [ __ ] cult paranormal
um exorcism coat you know and [ __ ]
even good spirits are possessing people
the spirit of God landed on Jesus after
he got baptized by [ __ ] John the
Baptist and God says [ __ ]
this one is with me and then all of a
sudden he can do Miracles so there is
some scripture would say that
Christianity is a is an exorcism called
the demon can possess people and God can
possess people which that's a big thing
in the
and early Christians there were well
what happened did Jesus get possessed by
God
and then he could do the [ __ ] then he
could do that then he could do all his
paranormal stuff or was he actually you
know what I mean when did it happen or
was he born as the angel of Jesus into
this body
was he physical or was he just a
spiritual Force
all that stuff is open to interpretation
in the scriptures and they they
interpreted it in many different ways
hence why there are so many different
denominations right Jesus is saying no
I'm real you can touch me see I'm not a
[ __ ] ghost I'm physical yeah but you
are the angel of Jesus born into a woman
you know [ __ ] and that all makes
sense because there was a Jewish angel
named Jesus spelled with z
and that's
he was an angel an archangel above
Gabriel
so it all starts making sense you know
be like the Gabriel it's like the angel
Gabriel possessing the body of a woman
and he was one of God's best sons and he
you can bypass
judgment and old script Old Testament
law if you put your faith in Jesus and
accept the blood that his blood
sacrificed during the damn
Jewish blood Magic Ritual where they let
the scapegoat go in the in the innocent
lamb is slaughtered and the [ __ ]
blood washes away the sins of the tribe
it's the same thing as
the blood of the innocent lamb Jesus his
blood saves everyone a long time you
know throughout time it's the blood of a
[ __ ] D of a [ __ ] Demi God
and they let they let the Evil Goat the
scapegoat they let him go Barabbas you
know Brabus wouldn't it yeah Barabbas
yes and uh he's you know the the
criminal
that's the [ __ ] scapegoat ritual
you know it happened in all the Passover
if I remember correctly it didn't happen
on a Passover
I don't know I don't think it's a
Passover but it's
um
yeah
so it's just Christian thinking
and
Christianity's been real interwoven with
possession and exorcism
evil spirits and spirits of the Evil
Dead
so Lorraine Warren and the demonologists
and [ __ ]
more what's his name [ __ ] um
what's Mr Warren's name uh
Ed Ed yeah
Ed's going to come at it from that
standpoint there's gonna be a demon
somewhere so just keep that in mind
whenever you're dealing with that Warren
Tom Sykes said the Warrens talked about
a real life haunted case where the
occupants walked into the house and
never came out straight up disappeared
it was straight on that old school show
One Step Beyond I kind of remember that
actually we might have talked about
because we did a show a long time ago
that was like from the Case Files of the
Warrens or something like that yeah and
I think I might have mentioned that on
there if I'm not mistaken but that was
like many years ago so I'm not really
sure but Ed Warren never what a great
short story of that would make that's
okay Ed Warren would never even
entertain any of the parapsychological
explanations everything was demons
pretty much
which that's a very foolish way of
[ __ ] interpreting what's going on and
I've seen this [ __ ] it was it the
parapsychologists were closer to the
truth if he has me
he also says real [ __ ] though the
Warrens probably helped a lot of people
who had nowhere else to turn for help
and for free yeah I mean I'll give them
that yeah oh they made money off of it
just not off the people just not off the
people themselves yeah
El padrino said uh only demon was the
non-principal that hit me with the
paddle I hated that statistics
uh Adriano Hammond you both looking
great thank you have you seen the skull
experiment yeah uh yeah we did a show
about it a long time ago that might be
one that we need to revisit I kind of
feel like because that was like years
ago we did that I remember I wrote I
read a whole book about it when I was a
teenager
and even saw the little photographs and
little Scrolls of [ __ ] paper that
they would get and the photographs I
thought there was something to it that
was after I saw the Poltergeist
but looking at it now Through The Eyes
of an adult
and knowing what they did I I don't
believe it
that's not the same that's not the same
thing as um what was it called when they
when they decided they were gonna make a
ghost that was the Philip experiment
right yeah yeah see that always kind of
like fascinated me because I always
wanted to see if that if that would work
skull experiments was basically seances
yeah that's what yeah
I think they faked all that though
I Pro I suspect that they probably did
yeah but it's it's been a long time
since I've looked into all the details
like I said we did a show about it but
that was like years and years ago
um also have you watched the doc on uh
Jesus the Shroud of Turin I've seen a
lot of different documentaries about
that a lot of problems with the shroud
of children a lot of problems with it
yeah I think it was made in the in the
Middle Ages it's not very old
I mean it's old but it's not as old as
you say it is and I think it was made in
the 1400s the image that's on it is not
an image that would have been
around a three-dimensional object it was
something that was two-dimensional
painted on it they showed the
differences it it would have been if it
was a wrapped around a three-dimensional
object it'd be very [ __ ] distorted
it was some kind of chemical burn
and it was done with a brush
I saw a thing one time where they did it
they almost did it like a bar relief
where it was just kind of like they had
a
kind of like a a like a flattened statue
of Jesus yeah it was like partially 3D
but it was kind of flat you know what I
mean yeah like like console like Han
Solo and Carbonite yeah like yeah and
then you put the uh fabric over that and
like kind of did a rubbing like you do a
gravestone rubbing and that like came
like really close pretty close yeah yeah
it was there was a huge industry of
selling fake
um holy relics to the Catholic church in
the Middle Ages and they knew they were
fake they still buy them because they
were like oh that's a good one yeah
followers will like that and we'll get
them to come to church oh boy another
Jesus is foreskin yeah so
if you could come up with a cook up a
good fake you could sell it to your
local church they loved it they're like
yeah they didn't give a [ __ ] they were
like this one anything that brought
people in yep anything that brought
people in because that's what you know
you didn't have anything else to do back
then well they were like well yeah it's
fake but we're saving people's Souls
yeah that's how they Justified it so
they didn't give they didn't give a crap
if it was real or not
Rumple foreskin
As Time Travelers took the Shroud back
to the Middle Ages to confuse the
faithful and spread atheism
it was yeah it was just kind of like uh
when they buried all those dinosaur
bones in there too like to so the world
is uh to fool us into the world being
like older than 6 000 years the ancient
Greeks would dig up dinosaur bones and
[ __ ] go yeah these are griffins you
know this is where a bunch of which
doesn't happen that's not a dumb that's
not a dumb thing to think
they found a [ __ ]
they found a giant tomb and it was
basically labeled to like a giant or a
demagogue and it was the bones of an
elephant and they're arranged in the
shape of a of a man because they didn't
know what it was they just found these
bones
and they go this must be a dude and they
put those bones in the shape of a man
and go there he is
we better give him a decent burial
so this is the way people thought
well yeah that's what I mean it's just
like you can't blame them for not really
knowing what the [ __ ] that was so it's
like they dig something up and be like
what the [ __ ] is this thing yeah and
they just kind of like put it in the
context of like what they knew it was it
was like an ancient Mammoth or something
yeah which like I said they didn't know
anything about that so you can't blame
them they weren't stupid they thought it
was a hero from old they were working
with what they had yeah we better bury
this [ __ ] this might be Hercules
himself
you know I mean just to be on the safe
side right yeah
all right so where were we okay so uh
yeah we got distracted by the demon okay
so uh yeah three ghosts and a demon
so now the demon now this is kind of
interesting Ed Warren apparently said
that the demon uh had probably been
dormant in the house for a long time and
then it was energized
by the oncoming puberty of the two small
daughters okay so he's talking about so
he's talking about Poltergeist activity
because like I said you know 95 I don't
know the exact percentage but 95 of like
Poltergeist cases are usually centered
around puberty and a lot of times it's
girls but not always yeah yeah not
always
so um that's probably what they thought
but he's just framing it in a demonic
you know kind of uh kind of framework
you know what I mean yeah
so uh Ed and Lorraine who by the way I'm
pretty sure they wrote a book about this
which the TV movie was based on they
tried to exercise the demons doing the
regular exorcism [ __ ] you know doing the
praying doing the holy water the you
know playing religious music in the
house trying to piss off the demon I
guess
um but as per usual and we've seen on
every episode of Haunting uh this just
makes the demon mad and at least they
admit that it makes a demon man but I
think in some ways it's kind of like
they're kind of like oh yeah all this
stuff we're doing it's making the demon
mad whereas like in real life if demons
existed they probably I won't give a
[ __ ] about that whatever you know what I
mean
so um apparently like while they were
doing their their thing
the Warrens and the smurls said that a
bunch of like dresser drawers and there
was like a mirror that was on the wall
and they started like shaking uh really
violently like when they were doing the
prayers and all that and uh this is
another thing that's a little bit hard
to believe
but apparently a message spontaneously
appeared on the mirror
and this message read you filthy bastard
get out of this house
not really sure if he was talking to Ed
yeah or if he was talking to it's the
only filthy bastard
too we don't really go in there and get
a [ __ ] Little Debbie Oatmeal pie oh
you got oatmeal pie that's not a
snickerdoodle one we're out of those oh
the Snickerdoodle man you ate that whole
box I think I had no I think I had two
of those the Snickerdoodle ones I think
are way better than the oatmeal pies I
know that's maybe sacrilegious to say
but the Snickerdoodle ones were
delicious Little Debbie has some new
flavors good snickerdoodle
yeah it's like an oatmeal pie but it's
got snickerdoodle cookies instead of
oatmeal cookies yeah and the it's a
little bit smaller in like the the cream
in the middle is thicker they're super
healthy man just it's [ __ ] all
protein
or something low calorie but first the
first some definitions of protein thank
you very much Trey Happy New Year I have
freaking covid so I'm in bed sort of
listening oh I'm sorry I hope you get
better soon but thank you very much
thank you very much and happy New Year
um
uh let's see
Tom Sykes says get the hell out shows up
on the fridge of the San Pedro Haunting
in alphabets yeah that's right
so these are kind of like some wordy
poltergeists we're talking about here
so um
yeah so Ed he is saying yeah the the
filthy bastard was uh directed toward
him probably now he was supposedly he
said in the book that he got uh choked
by someone's hands like invisible hands
and then started having like flu-like
symptoms which might have been just the
flu you know that's because that that's
a thing that happens the filthy bastard
was a reference to Ed
his wife Lorraine and their 15 year old
girlfriend
yeah maybe the demon knew about that
yeah
[Laughter]
it's true
I don't think she was 15 though was he I
don't remember we're young
yeah they had like some uh they had kind
of a weird thing going on yeah the weird
threesome
[Laughter]
yeah
well she was a Biblical marriage that's
probably how they thought about it too
from the Old Testament yeah well you
because you know how like Ed Warren was
just kind of like well it's in the Bible
so I'm allowed to do it yeah and you're
not allowed to [ __ ] about it because
you're just a woman so that's fine yeah
Christian's always talking about we're
gonna have a [ __ ]
I mean they taught the Christian uh
marriage Christian relationship or
something like that yeah Christian Bate
Christian marriage was between a man and
a woman and a woman and a woman and a
woman and a teenage girl and a teenage
girl and all the handmaidens of your
women right they all belong to the man
yeah Charlemagne had a [ __ ] ton of wives
which I think uh a lot of dudes would
like to go back to that actually yeah it
was like Islam
you could have as many women as you
could afford yeah that's all what it's
more natural
not for me it's not
it's not natural
yeah women were kind of evolved to be in
harems
most eighty percent of women yeah of
course eighty percent
eighty percent of women oh he's gonna
prove it to you right now right now you
should probably just like stop talking
eighty percent of that she snapped the
same 20 of the men I'll Chase it after
anybody Big Brother share a alpha than
to accept a beta they'll just be single
if they don't so what ends up happening
especially if you look at real Rich
dudes they got three or four [ __ ]
wives basically they're just not only
married to one but they all got houses
and they [ __ ] yeah the wives know
because the wife ages out she's like
yeah I don't want to [ __ ] you anymore
just make sure the bills are paid go do
your own thing and then they're all
doing that
that's what they do Mega says keep
digging Tom yeah he will come on I know
what it is
no you don't but okay
[Laughter]
oh that's right there it's right there
that's right you don't represent you
don't represent I forgot that Tom is
always right about everything at all
times no ways let me tell you let me
tell you all something
Jenny in no way represents the average
woman
in no way she's not average in any way
she's her she's her own [ __ ] little
phenomenon
average women like my own phenomenon yes
I cannot like that yeah average women
would would rather like I said they'd
rather share Alpha than to [ __ ] be
with a beta
especially if they're real young when
they get older it's different you know
they're limited change in different you
know over the years in their
as they give Tom watch is a bunch of
[ __ ] on the manosphere section of
like YouTube and thinks it's all true
some of it some but I've been there I
know exactly what they're talking about
oh and also he thinks everyone else's
experience is the same as his experience
no I don't think that at all
the average guy never could never live
like me they don't
the average guy's a lot more lonely than
I am
poor things that is the way it is
like I said
eighty percent of the women are chasing
the same top 20 of the dudes
they're lucky to get laid they don't
have girlfriends for the most part
they're mostly
single most of the time I was never
single not unless I was in the army or
off doing some other [ __ ]
so at times you were at times I were
yeah but it was by choice okay the
average guy's kind of an in sale
I don't know if I'd say that yeah
there's oh okay that's I I forgot you're
right about everything yeah it's true
just look at the statistics okay all
right well women don't like the truth
man they want to [ __ ] change it out
it's most dudes [ __ ] are not real
why are you talking about this [ __ ]
okay all right this is an Andrew Tate
Show get the [ __ ] off
that [ __ ] there
he's [ __ ] funny that guy I like that
guy of course you do I like him he's
funny yeah of course you do because he's
a total douchebag but I don't take
everything he says seriously but I like
that he [ __ ] trolls people he's
partially trolling there is a lot of
Truth in what he's saying but it's not
the absolute truth there is no absolute
truth everything is kind of
everything can be kind of uh
bit
character and Charisma can bend a lot of
rules that you that's usually what
you're seeing that's what you're seeing
there's some dudes that can just die I'm
gonna do this and then it works
but that's part of nature you're not
violating nature when you do that
says actually sexual frustration is
supposed to be a factor in Poltergeist
activity yeah yeah it probably is I
can't yeah it's like if pretty much any
kind of um actually it's this is kind of
like a sideways thing but I was because
I was watching hoarders last night
but I was kind of thinking that maybe
and you said this in regards to your
[ __ ] as well was that people that
have a really really strict upbringings
or are either by their own personality
or by you know a force imposed on them
from outside are supposed to like
suppress their emotions you know I mean
like if they grow up in a really strict
household for example
then uh then they will lash out in other
ways
and like you said I think in your case
you said there's like Poltergeist
activity and I've seen some other things
where that happened
whereas uh I was watching a show on
Hoarders last night where the woman had
grown up in like a Jehovah's Witness and
her dad was like super controlling and
she wasn't allowed to do anything so
when she got to be an adult she was like
well I'm just gonna buy [ __ ] because you
know that's that was like the way her
way of like taking over control of her
life and uh and I said and I though this
is also weird but this is um that's kind
of the same psychology as like some uh
like some Eating Disorders like anorexia
because when you feel like you don't
have any control over your life it has
to come out somehow so control has to
come out somehow so anorexics will you
know they're like well I can control
what I eat with what I put in my body
like how much I weigh so it's kind of
like all on a spectrum you know what I'm
saying
Tammy said I read somewhere that the
happiest women are single I believe that
and the happiest men are married the
unhappiest women are married and the
unhappiest men are single
uh yeah I believe that that lines up
more with my own experience yeah
probably true that's why I never
encouraged men to get married do not get
married
don't do it stay safe if you want women
to be happy don't marry her well if you
want women on you if you want women to
be happy just just don't uh don't pair
up with them at all because women are
much happier when they're single if you
run into women that think like that
don't go out with it don't go out with
her
uh let's see where was I okay
this is your fault women I know every
everything's our fault we're used to it
um Jeffy art said neither of you are
what I would call average not by a
[ __ ] long shot yeah I know Zach says
you're both your own phenomenon that's
why we like you so much
but he projects I never considered
myself a phenomenon before and he
projects her her value system I don't
though I'm very an average person I'm
very like that I'm very aware that other
people are not like me she comes down to
the [ __ ] biker bar with me where the
average people are and she's like oh my
God
that's who it is I wasn't like that what
are you talking about
I absolutely did not do music the
fashion set I absolutely did not do that
all right so I don't know what you were
I don't know you interpreted some weird
[ __ ] okay because the thing about it is
that you have uh well your problem is
that you have like a a very rigid way
that you think everything works and so
you fit everything into that even when
it's nothing to do with that because
you've told me many times it's like oh
you think this and that I'm like no I
literally have never thought that ever
but okay okay you know what I mean so I
didn't think that at all okay I'm just
saying it's not really my scene like I
said I grew up in Daytona so I'm really
familiar with that kind of stuff and
it's like I'm just not really into it
it's very much like it is a Mississippi
that's what I mean not very much into it
either you know you know what I mean but
I I know what it is
okay and I know I know how they are
they're not like us
not in the way that they do things that
doesn't necessarily yeah it's bad I grew
up around people that were not like me
so I'm very my family's like that I'm
very very aware
I was very aware from a very young age
that most people were not like me so I
would never in a million years think
that other people were like me that's
the last thing I would think right you
know what I mean because I'm very aware
that they're not
so I don't assume that kind of I don't
assume anything about anything about
anybody okay because I don't know I
don't know you you know what I mean okay
so I'm just saying all right
um
Zach says as frustrating as it can be
it's stuff like that why I thank God for
making me queer
exactly
or says Tom is projecting his projection
yeah he does he does that no no he does
that no I'm just letting Jenny off the
hook okay right whatever
well gee thank you but Zach Zach I'll
[ __ ] get on you about the gays too
they got the average gays I don't even
like the average gays they're as bad as
the average straight people all right if
I could I got friends that are cool gays
and they don't like they don't like that
they don't like average gays all right
and [ __ ] we start first of all the
fashion sets is [ __ ] crazy okay uh
just I could get I could get Toby in
here and he'll go off for hours
you know he's old leather daddy he'll
talk he'll talk for hours about average
gays he says they're they're trying to
be straight people they're like they're
it's just it's just funny to hear him
talk about it but I understand what he's
talking about
Tammy said Is there going to be a new
t-shirt featuring the new Channel logo
yeah eventually we're gonna make one
yeah I mean I specifically made the new
logo so it would be easier yeah to shoot
uh to shoot the thing because yeah and
I'll do it in that color if I can get
that color green I do like green I do
like that green yeah I'd get it I could
do well the thing about it though is
that if you're gonna screen print it
then you usually have to do a layer of
white and then a layer of green over it
because if you just do a layer of green
on the shirt then it doesn't show up as
bright it'll be a little darker yeah
because I won't I'll try because I've
done it before with red ink and it
doesn't really show up all that good you
have to put a layer of white underneath
that neon green might work though
I don't know it depends yeah I mean yeah
I'll do I'll do an experimental one yeah
you'd have to get one that was I can't
do a two color because if it's too hard
it's too hard well we don't have the
machine to like set up we you know to do
the uh to line it up and everything like
that
so
um all right so where were we
so Ed had the flu and he blamed it on
the demons so that's where we work
so uh so the Warrens after they left I
guess like all the haunting [ __ ] like
kind of calmed down after a little while
but then a little while later they got
like way way worse and this is the point
where Jax Merle said that he was
repeatedly raped by a succubus which
they showed in the movie and it was like
the most hilarious scene in there uh and
he said that the succubus appeared to
him as a scaly old woman not a man
dressed as a woman as in the movie but a
scaly old woman with red eyes and green
gums which is very specific
not green teeth
I just drink up green gums so what color
were the teeth then bright white I guess
how would you notice that the gums were
green because I feel like I wouldn't
even notice what color people's gums
were
you reading too much into it I mean
that's what he saw that's my deal His
Image it was his image it was it was he
made it up
that's what I mean well we'll see in a
way that's even weirder like if he made
it up because I'm like why would you
make up something like that like that
weird specific detail because you would
think it's like oh you know oh the red
eyes that's you know everybody's got
that but you know what I mean like of
all the scary [ __ ] yeah they have red
eyes are black guys but green gums
that's bizarre I've had I've had dreams
where a character and a Dream came at me
and I know picked out a little detail on
that character and it was [ __ ] weird
like you know okay green I'm looking at
some dude he's talking to me now look at
his gums his gums are green and I
remember that
you know what I mean second that's
probably that's what he's talking Tammy
said maybe she didn't have any teeth
yeah maybe that's what it is see I
didn't even think of that because I'm
stupid
but yeah
um maybe that's what it was yeah so yeah
you would notice it more like if the
guns were green and she didn't have any
teeth I'm not worried about it
yeah but we're trying to like make a
show out of it I'm not worried about it
I know I don't think it happened I know
you want to talk about your your
theories about look at that look at her
look at her I know you'd rather talk
about your theories of like uh gender or
whatever but it's like we're not doing a
show about that nothing to do with Jim
you can do your own uh you can do your
own channel
man
what I'm hungry almost
dude we're only we're not even through
the through this case
about [ __ ] and I can't even get
that's a lot of [ __ ] yeah you were
Zach says imagine what the guy described
riding you with some giant maniacal
smile right it's like that yeah so um
red eyes and green gums is succubus uh
also Janet said I should not to be
outdone I guess she's like oh yeah um
demon also raped me as well but hers was
like a dark figure and that she could
hear pig noises coming from Behind the
Walls while it was going on which that's
I mean you know there's some people that
would pay for that
yeah that does seem like it's almost
like again that's a very second yeah
that's a very specific sexual fetish
yeah I kind of feel like there was
another case where they said that they
were actually raped by pigs yeah or like
pig people like two-legged pigs you know
what I mean like upright pigs
was that this case and I'm just like
having like an exaggerated
I don't remember I thought there was
another one where there was like pigs
involved
these are people that don't do not I
know I mean I know Amityville Horror had
like the whole Jody situation but that's
not what I'm thinking about I'm talking
about I'm talking about pigs raping
people yeah I'll try to picture that I
mean these are not people that do not
come from a farm in the background
pigs I just don't picture a pig being a
kind of like a sexually sexually uh uh
[ __ ] foreboding [ __ ] the
threatening creature yeah here comes the
pig I don't know man you see a pig
coming at you with a pig what do they
call it that's not a business it's not
even it's not even a dick I mean it's
like
Pig basically caught a lot of pigs male
Pig you're talking about something about
six inches seven inches long that's a
big old like the bigger round is a damn
straw and [ __ ] um shaped like a
corkscrew and it's prehensile it [ __ ]
finds the wee yeah
this looks like a tentacle off of a
[ __ ] and probably like inside a human
like they wouldn't even notice
that's like a tentacle off of a [ __ ]
like yeah what's that it's like octopus
or something centipede like whatever
they're reading into this [ __ ] maybe
they've [ __ ] seen a [ __ ] a horse
you know what I mean or you know a big
old [ __ ] stallion walking in you know
what I mean and see now Jimmy horse yeah
and it looks like that happened more
that's what I'm saying because you know
[ __ ] because that now that would be
scaring up around horses I mean the
anatomy is very similar just giant size
you know what I mean and [ __ ] I had
to walk around a [ __ ]
stud breeding studs you know which they
have not been gelded
and those [ __ ] are impressive
no man could ever compete with that
that's why the Ancients were always
saying well yeah when Zeus comes down
he's gonna [ __ ] be like a bull or a
horse and [ __ ] have sex with women
that's what they're talking about
um very impressive
you know if you're a size queen it's not
then that's the way you're gonna go if
you're what but this pig thing pigs pigs
aren't working with much
[ __ ] I've seen Pig breeding you know
uh it's no nah
you know it's a demon if a demon was
gonna come and get you it would come at
you like a size of a [ __ ] it would be a
horse but see maybe it's a demon Pig so
it's like a pig so he's got like a man
dick on it or something right that's
what I'm saying we're not talking about
like real [ __ ] here right yeah so I'm
just saying yeah and this one like I
said it wasn't even she just said that
she heard pig noises like coming from
because her her one was like it was just
a dark figure that she saw you know what
I mean I've always wondered what it was
you know my mom being a trainer and
everything and we've noticed that all
these young
teenage girls just so interested in
these damn horses I never it was always
kind of
and then as soon as they're old enough
to date guys all of a sudden they don't
want to ride anymore they don't want
they're not interested in horses anymore
it makes you wonder what their what kind
of Psychology was going on about getting
on top of this big muscular [ __ ]
beast and riding it see I always
wondered if there was some [ __ ] the My
Little Pony thing might have had a
different I don't I don't know
Victor's I'm not in that business
anymore Victor said maybe she just
scissored with a pig yeah maybe yeah
yeah this is maybe maybe that's what it
was yeah
you could just cuddle with the pig pigs
are really smart
too bad they're delicious also oh well
yeah what are you gonna do
so uh so yeah
so all of this crazy [ __ ] is going on
clearly so the smurls said that they
went to the Roman Catholic Church to get
an exorcism but the church was just like
nah we don't want to get involved in
that situation
so the Warrens got their go-to guy
father McKenna he's a dude that's he's
been on a haunting I'm pretty sure I
mean I've seen him before he hangs out
with the warrants all the time
so they got him to come to the house and
do the rights himself like without the
backing this was the illegal exorcism I
don't think he went like Whole Hog with
the exorcism he can't really do that oh
God we'll kick your ass or something but
he just like went there and did what he
could do like without the church right
so McKenna goes there he does one
exorcism and of course it doesn't work
the first time and uh everything got
worse as usually happens
so the next person to come in uh to see
if they could get to the bottom of this
was another medium Mary Alice rinkman
uh she came in and also said oh yeah
there's four entities in here I'm sure
probably the Warrens like you know
filter in ahead of time
and she's like yeah and one of them's a
demon just like the Warren said because
they're always right
so she said that two of the other ones
were actually like dead people she said
one was a murderer named Patrick who had
been killed by a Lynch Mob because like
I said you always need some kind of
murder or True Crime going on in the
house or otherwise it's boring you don't
want boring ghosts you have to have
interesting ghosts and the other was an
old woman which is what the Warren said
too and this old woman's name was
Abigail
and rankman apparently didn't know who
the fourth entity was
so father for Canada comes back in and
does a second exorcism
uh which also didn't do Jack uh and then
after this point it got so bad that the
smurl said that like [ __ ] started
happening at other locations like weird
paranormal like a poltergeist kind of
[ __ ] would happen like at Jack's
workplace and also
um and they I think they showed this in
the movie The Haunted too like when they
went on vacation like they went to this
Campground or something like some weird
[ __ ] happened like some weird Phantom
wind type crap and like you know stuff
moving around on its own and it happened
like when they were on vacation too like
it was following them
so
at this point they don't really know
what else to do so they decide that
they're going to go to the Press I think
they were kind of hoping that they would
be able to shame the Catholic Church
into helping them because prior to this
like Catholic Church they don't want to
help them out so they said maybe if we
go to the press and make us think about
it then maybe they'll come and like do
something to help us
now what ended up happening with that
though and this is another thing they
portrayed in the movie is that
you know uh they probably got a lot more
attention than they bargained for and
that they actually wanted because now
they have like a bunch of weirdos like
uh sleeping in front of their house like
camping on the front lawn uh they have
newspaper people like hanging out in
front of their house all the time they
can't leave the house without like
getting asked questions [ __ ] like that
so you know what I mean
um now after this again uh the demon
activity or the Poltergeist activity
whatever you want to call it got like
way way worse
now on the night that Jack actually like
went and told the media about it uh
Janet said that she would got picked up
and choked and thrown against the wall
like uh you know just by an invisible
person or whatever uh and Jack claimed
oh see this is what I was thinking of
Jack claimed that he was raped again but
this time by a creature that looked like
a pig on two legs so that's what I was
thinking of so he was raped by a pig man
pig man
pig man yeah man
can you imagine like Tom's imagining it
yeah I'm going yeah I think they're
sitting there saying raped by a pig man
the Jack's Merle story
he's in there saying he's gay but he
doesn't have any gay friends same thing
but and [ __ ] we were talking and I'm
just one like this this [ __ ] raped by
a pig man thing that make a good gay
porn film
yeah you don't think there's already one
we gotta look for it all right rule 34.
yeah that that make that make a good
porn film and it would be kind of like
um it sounds like a Chuck tingle book
yeah raped by a pig I think I think I
think I would do it kind of Greek you
know what I'm talking about you'd have
seders raped by a pig man in my own butt
yeah you'd have like Crusaders you have
like pan out there with his flutes and
his [ __ ] horns and [ __ ] [ __ ]
having his way with these dudes and then
[ __ ] the pig man comes up and tries
to beat [ __ ] pants high score and
starts going after these other dudes
[ __ ] I'll get I'll get i'll get
[ __ ] uh I'll give Victor to write it
we'll write up a whole screenplay I got
a friend that's in porn we'll make
yeah
I made a friend I made a friend on local
porn around here
his husband all right you got to look
her up [ __ ] Quinn Studios
I said if they told me if I ever wanted
to shoot a scene [ __ ] just [ __ ]
hit him up [ __ ] they got to work for
me they don't pay though see Jenny get
mad what it's volunteer porn no you know
so they don't pay much oh you know Oh I
thought you said they didn't pay at all
I was like okay I'm not doing porn for
free they pay but I'm like that's not
like that's barely worth driving over
there
[Laughter]
75 bucks
ditto that's what they paid dude
think of that
75 bucks I guess that would add up if
you went every but yeah but how often do
they make movies though like maybe once
a month for that yeah no they might give
you a job once a month you can't I mean
it'd be different if it was like every
day yeah
that might be kind of worth it but these
are little local Studios
of just really regular looking people
that make because you know they don't
need these big companies to
Market anything anymore they sell that
[ __ ] on [ __ ] like
minivids and [ __ ] mini vids is the
one that they do a lot of that [ __ ] on
where you could say how you poor
Ben says this is what happens when you
put demons into pigs Pigman rapists yep
yeah see that's what happens yeah Victor
said oh he's coming Victor is coming up
with a Chuck tingle okay yeah Garcia
raped raped by a pig man on Flag Day in
a Starbucks in my butt yeah
then
[Laughter]
there's a butt inside of a butt
and that butt is also watching that but
that butt is in that butt watch on the
other foot
jerking off to the butt
one butt jerking off to the other butt
oh my God
imagine trying to imagine how you're
butt jerking off yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
okay I've said this before but Chuck
tangle is a [ __ ] genius yeah
one of my drug dealers my steroid drug
dealers were it was a uh was a muscle
gay porn star
he could come up with some [ __ ] like
that he covers some [ __ ] like that it's
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
actually Kenny never met him I showed
her pictures of him and I showed you
pictures of him didn't I I don't know
you showed me pictures of people all the
time I don't remember who they are he's
a gay porn star
but he's got a girlfriend he's gay for
pay
just for pay
I thought the men in gay porn made more
than men in straight porn oh yeah we'll
see yeah so that gives you an incentive
right there yeah but he's but like he
sells his own [ __ ] you know what I mean
like he's another one because straight
men and porn don't think they don't make
all that much money well because there's
not much demand and it's like that's you
know his girlfriend is a bodybuilder too
but she's evidently not in any of that
[ __ ] he was you know yeah
yeah [ __ ]
he's all right though
I don't think he's straight I don't
think straight dude could do what he's
doing I think it's I think it's his
cover story
yeah I don't know about that well like I
said people's uh people's sexualities
are very yeah nebulous
well he he's like well dude
I was like well what did your girlfriend
think about you dude isn't that this and
that because she know about that she
goes oh yeah she knows but you know I'm
not gay or anything you know I'm not you
know it's as well well you know it's
just well you're bisexual though and
he's like no I'm not bisexual they're up
straight and I'm saying but dude what
are you talking about look at what
you're doing
and he's like dude it's not like love or
anything I'm not kissing these dudes
like what
you were
about like what other people are doing
with their genitalia he showed me
he showed you his genitalia no he showed
me a video
okay yeah
and I was just like dude look what you
doing maybe talking about man and he's
like and he's like [ __ ] oh no man
[ __ ] you know you're right you worry
too much about like I was like no I
don't think so man
no I don't really give a crap what you
do it's like I don't you know what I
mean I don't really think I don't like
labels man yeah I don't like it well I
just no I'm gonna say it's just it's too
it's too rigid
I think the dude's bisexual I don't
think there's a problem with it but you
know he's just saying he's straight yeah
but it's like why does it matter like if
like no what you call him why it
mattered to him why does it matter it
mattered to him
I'm just saying it shouldn't matter it
matter to him it doesn't make any
difference okay
keep telling yourself that no I'm just
saying it doesn't make any difference
what you call it it's just like silly to
like
it's silly to like put words on
everything it's just kind of you know
what I mean I'm just not like that well
that doesn't mean other people aren't
yeah but
I don't care what they what they're like
I just know what I'm like that's all
that matters
all that matters I only care about my
own views of it I don't really care well
yeah I'm very aware of that
that that's the only everything he cares
about and yeah I'm just straight up and
he'll admit it I'm straight up like no I
give a [ __ ] what you think yeah he only
cares about himself he just said it
like I said I already I got my own rules
I already know that uh Tom psych says in
the Paranormal Activity next of kin film
which I haven't seen actually I've seen
the first one but I haven't seen the
other ones one of the characters
comments on how good the female pig's
butt looked and asked the Amish dude if
they all looks that good
that's awesome I'm gonna have to watch
that movie now just what movie was that
Paranormal Activity next of Ken okay
wait which one is that like how many
Paranormal Activity movies are there
does anybody know
lit I've literally only seen the first
one I know there's a [ __ ] time but I
don't I don't know how many there are
that's funny Tom Sykes also says Jack
and Janet's Merle look like brother and
sister kinda they uh they did a bit well
I'll hold on let's back up what did the
Amish guy say
what did Thomas guy say did he say no
they all look that good or no that one's
exceptionally good what how do you
answer that question
it's just like what if what a funny
thing to like have occurred to you like
you just see a pig and you're like look
at that ass on that yeah I never would
have thought of that
Porky got back
[ __ ] funny you know you people are
[ __ ] terrible shame on y'all
don't be ashamed it's funny
uh Mega says next to Ken was the last
one
yeah but what number is that though
like I don't even
I don't even know I'm sure it went in
all kind of like crazy directions the
first one was pretty good but
I haven't seen any of the other ones
because I was like oh the first one was
good but I didn't really feel the need
to like see any of the other ones you
know what I mean so you know
so yeah Pig on two legs that's that's
where we got distracted
so uh Jack shows up on a local
television show I don't know I kind of
feel like because weren't the smells on
like some daytime talk shows talking
about the pig raping
I thought they were on I don't know if
it was Donahue or I think I kind of feel
like Donahue might have been a little
too classy for that but I mean you know
unless I'm remembering it wrong but I'm
pretty sure I saw these these two on a
daytime talk show of some stripe maybe
it was salad Jesse Raphael maybe it was
Geraldo no I'm pretty sure it wasn't
real though
I wanted to say it was Donahue but I
don't think I don't think Donahue would
have like he's like we're not doing Pig
rape okay this is a serious [ __ ] show
you know I don't know
so he shows up on TV Donahue's wasn't a
serious show though no I'm just saying
that Donahue pretended to be serious
well yeah that well that's what I'm
saying it's like he would have had it's
like we need to have some semblance of
like you know
decorum on this show so we can't do like
yeah I got raped by a pig man yeah but
he would do some [ __ ] like that it's
just that he would try to reword that
[ __ ] some fun but really when you
look to die he was exactly the same as
[ __ ] Ola what's his name [ __ ]
Jerry Springer it was just saying it's
just that the way he handled it was I
remember they all ended up in the end
being exactly the same well yeah because
everybody watched Jerry Springer yes
they all ended up being like because
everybody's like hey everybody on here
is the worst let's watch it was fake all
that shit's fake though people it was
it's all fake it was fake Yeah well yeah
like another somebody who was on that
[ __ ] well all those people like um you
know they'd have it's like hey it's a
mother and daughter and they're both
like banging the same guy like for money
and he buys us five million dollar
houses and all this other kind of stuff
it's like those are just actors or
people that are willing to talk or
people that just are willing to they're
like hey you want to do this and like
get in a fight and everything like that
we'll give you like 300 or whatever it
was they're like
evidently a lot of it had to do with
being flown to this area studio and they
put you I mean if they feed you and give
you free booze and then have a party
with you
and then give me 300 on top of that just
to come on TV and like have some
[ __ ] about how like I have a fetish
about what's up and they didn't have a
bunch of them at once I see that they'd
film a bunch of them at once so you'd
have like
the the cast from like seven or eight
shows all at once in the same hotel
right next to each other I'll be
partying and [ __ ] that's really what it
was about yeah it's before social media
that was kind of I would say that was
almost kind of like the beginnings of
social media I mean people didn't have
anything better it was like reality TVs
if that's what they wanted to call it it
wasn't real but well like I said yeah
they were either actors or they were
just people willing to like go on a
beach and that's act a fool for money
he's for money yeah they'd be like yeah
we don't have any shame come on
they were looking for strippers any kind
of in any kind of two-bit Entertainer
like one of our friends was one of those
[ __ ] he was with the big wings and
[ __ ] Jacob yeah he looked like the devil
and he was doing that [ __ ] in Central
America he'd been on all their [ __ ]
my boyfriend is a Satanist and he was
the Satanist and my boyfriend is a
[ __ ] even though it's hilarious
because he's like yeah nicest guy in the
world [ __ ] funny but he looked freaky
as [ __ ]
and he made a whole living just going on
these damn talk shows for a while yeah
and like and like posing is different
like posing as different things every
time yeah because you know how they
would do like they'd have the talk show
and they'd be like oh you know my my
daughter is marrying a Satanist and then
they'd have like the guy come out and
then everybody in the audience be like
whoo yes
[ __ ] hilarious yeah [ __ ] Jacob
Angels his name yeah he's still around
he's still around he still does stuff
yeah he did he did her tattoo he's a
tattoo artist yeah he did this tattoo
yeah but he was also suspension he'd
[ __ ] put the stakes to himself he
married a friend of ours Aurora they
were married for a little while but he'd
do all he taught her suspension they'd
do all this [ __ ] suspension acts and
he make a bunch of money in Colombia
where he came from
but he would do all those talk shows
Colombia Venezuela [ __ ] Chile Peru he
could go all over [ __ ] Central and
South America doing talk shows pretended
to be [ __ ] somebody's boyfriend or
somebody's [ __ ] husband or and he
looked like the devil
just he looked fantastic Skitty fangs
bald head he didn't have horns installed
did he
um I thought he had I thought he had he
had little spikes he had spikes like uh
inserted yeah
um he had them put like so uh what do
they call that subdermal where they put
like the screw underneath and you can
screw different things I Mean Gene
Simmons look like a [ __ ] he had these
[ __ ] fantastic huge boots huge devil
wings
and uh he could [ __ ]
stick spikes through himself and hooks
and [ __ ] do you have a split song as
well yeah I think he did I thought he
had his plan and he was a
ex-military guy
he was a trained infantry sniper from
the Colombian Army and his brother was a
commissioned officer who was being
accused of a big old [ __ ]
Massacre that happened it was real
famous in Colombia where he ordered a
bunch of people to be [ __ ] basically
killed in this big [ __ ] firefight he
nothing happened to his brother but it
was justified but he was his brother was
real famous for that but he was a
Columbia sniper we look at him you think
he was just some [ __ ] crazy
Freakazoid but he was real disciplined
real
military real right wing you know he
wasn't
wishy-washy he was [ __ ] real he was a
good dude I liked him but he just
couldn't make it in the United States it
was he had to go back to Central America
where he could make a money make money
he wasn't shocking enough for here I
guess
there's a lot of guys like that here
that's true yeah Tom Sykes says back to
the Smurfs yeah yeah I mean you know
sorry eventually we still we have two
more cases to get through damn so it's
gonna be a long show well yeah that's
what uh that's what I was telling you uh
so yeah so Jack shows up on the TV I
don't remember what show it was I
remember seeing it but I don't remember
what show it was
so that eventually did work uh in their
goal of shaming the church into
investigating the case so finally uh the
diocese in Scranton gave their blessing
to a third exorcism so this was the one
that was backed by the church they had
done freelance exorcisms before that but
this third one uh the church had they
had the backing of the church on this
one so father McKenna does the third one
now uh it appeared that this time I
guess because the church was behind it
uh it worked because the Paranormal
Activity reportedly stopped after this
exorcism
however only three months later
Jack actually came out and said that he
saw a shadowy figure in the house that
beckoned to him so you know uh and they
said that all the like foul smells and
all that kind of stuff and the violent
Poltergeist activity started up again
like three months later
so at that point they're just like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] and they moved away they moved
back to Wilkes bar where they were from
originally
and apparently they didn't have any more
uh disturbances at their new house so it
didn't follow them now they did do a
fourth exorcism at the old house which
the Chase Street house in uh in West
Pittston in 1988 and that seemed to have
halted uh the activity there as far as I
know like nothing else there has been
reported somebody else bought the duplex
after that um I don't know who lives
there now but in the 80s or like not too
long after they did the fourth exorcism
somebody named Deborah Owens bought it
and she said that she hadn't witnessed
anything weird in there at all and she
didn't really know what everybody was
talking about and please get off my lawn
it was just kind of that kind of thing
um so you know
uh as I mentioned the Warrens wrote a
book called The Haunted actually no the
Warrens didn't write it it was written
by um a newspaper reporter named Robert
Curran and that was actually published
in 1986 but it was like kind of about
the Warrens uh you know involvement and
stuff like that uh the book didn't
really get great reviews I'm gonna say
uh they said it was very poorly written
and that the story was a little bit
unbelievable which yeah raped by a
pigman that's that's a little bit out
there now uh as I mentioned we did talk
about the movie that was made from it it
was made in uh it was actually made for
TV and it was broadcast in 1991 and it's
just called The Haunted and actually the
movie's pretty good as long as you're
not like
it sticks to the you know the the broad
outlines of their story it's as long as
you watch it like not really thinking
that it's real then you might enjoy it
because like I said some of their claims
were a little bit out there but you know
what I mean it's still a decent movie
though like it had to like some good
actors in it I I really I liked it
anyway and it's kind of free on um I
think it's free on YouTube or it was I
think that's where we watched it but
that was like uh you know a while back
so let's talk about the San Pedro case
which is uh sometimes called the Jackie
Hernandez case because that's the name
of the woman that was like at the center
of it like I said this kind of similar
this is what really so similar to the
Doris bitter case which if you don't
know was uh the case that the entity was
based on from 1982 that I sometimes get
them like confused with each other
because the details are so similar but
they're two completely different cases
so yeah so we're talking about the San
Pedro case now or actually before we do
that let me run to the bathroom let's go
ahead and play the commercials well oh
okay um commercial time anyway hold on
hold on okay so all right I'm gonna play
a couple commercials I'm gonna run to
the bathroom and then we'll be right
back in just a minute
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
advice
[Music]
and darkness
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
don't believe me
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's enough of that uh sorry
I was laughing at Jeffy Arts comment
raped by a pig man until the Warrens
came now please get off my lawn to
Jack's Merle story
[Laughter]
I would totally read that book as well
somewhere to get me another drink there
you go thank you very much
there we go now we're going to talk
about the San Pedro case this should be
good because it's not uh you know
spoiler alert not as much Pig rape in
this one uh unfortunately
[Laughter]
I wish we had some pig rape the Tom Ross
story so that's like another shirt but
uh but yeah there's some other weird
[ __ ] going on in this one this one was
actually
um
I don't know I always kind of like
really like this case because man some
weird [ __ ] went on in this one and I
feel like it's not as well known as like
maybe some other ones do you kind of
feel like that which one the San Pedro
case I don't remember Jackie Hernandez
uh sounds familiar uh which one was that
you know the you know the one with the
attic and the guy with the picture the
very famous picture of the guy with the
attic that got pulled up into the you
know what I'm talking about
you'll know what I'm talking about okay
[Music]
you know all about this game you're
talking about the guy that went up in
the attic yeah I just fought and fought
the Poltergeist up in there yeah I saw a
guy yeah okay well I don't know if he
saw it well I don't know if he saw a guy
but he got like pulled up to the ceiling
like by a rope yeah this is actually a
good case this is uh
the same guy that attacked Taff yeah
Taff yeah Taff investigating this yeah
it's not not Taft like the fat President
Taft with two F's okay
right
foreign
just with tea in it yeah we're having
well we were having boozy or Arnold
Palmer's the thing is I'm gonna had me
worried about this is that this has that
artificial sweetener in there
now sometimes artificial sweetener
breaks down under in the presence of
alcohol and it gets bitter but it seems
to be holding I have never noticed that
ever in my whole entire I've noticed it
yeah I have it although I will I will
admit that different artificial
sweeteners taste different to me
I'm like I'm not alcohol with him it
[ __ ] [ __ ] up that artificial
sweetness like for example for a while
we had Splenda and I was putting that in
the coffee and that tasted funny to me
but then I bought Sweet and Low and that
tasted normal
I like them all
but they're okay
I actually had out of them all I like
saccharin which is that's the one
everybody hates but I like I like sacred
but I don't think I've had any saccharin
for a really long time
Tom Sykes said a haunting TV show did an
episode similar to this case with
activity in the attic and someone being
hung or some [ __ ] like that yeah they
did didn't they and what was it called
um what wasn't there one called monster
in the Attic or that was just called The
Attic or something like that on a
haunting
I think it was just called The Attic we
haven't done that I think we watched it
recently but I need to see we need to do
a show we should probably do a show on
that yeah
yeah Zach says aren't some of the
artificial sweeteners worse for you than
actual sugar no
I don't know I kind of feel like maybe
they might be but I don't really know I
don't I don't really think it makes that
much of a difference to be honest with
you you don't live long enough for any
of that [ __ ] to [ __ ] take effect they
used to think that Sakura would give you
cancer there's no there's they were
injecting so much of that [ __ ] into my
city I mean yeah I mean you'd really
really have to like
have a lot of it like before you'd have
to be one it was the same with MSG they
would come out and say that [ __ ]
monosuit
glutamate I got her [ __ ] cheese
trying to be my my my my uh [ __ ]
crutch for speaking on how to speak not
that drunk
yeah a lot of sodium glutamate yeah but
MSG you said it wrong a bunch of times
though I had to [ __ ] so I was fixing it
this is why I don't say anything when I
get drugs
she gets like this okay because I'ma fix
it
MSG [ __ ] had they would say oh I
would give you a headache I'd give you
cancer blah blah blah blah and then you
end up going to the Chinese restaurant
no MSG you know they're [ __ ] we don't
use MSG
they miss G was a [ __ ] Japanese made
flavor enhancer that they put in things
and they still use it today they've had
no problem with MSG but here they people
thought it was something bad msg's
[ __ ] delicious you can get it in a
salt shaker if you know if it markets to
have everything
it'll make everything taste better
shake a little bit of MSG in it in the
recipe
and it just brightens everything tastes
really good I like it it was good in
Chinese food too just
don't believe what you hear there's
nothing wrong with MSG it's similar to
salt
yeah I mean it's just like a flavor
enhancer yeah
it's a flavor enhancer it's all it would
if you can't if you don't want to
enhance something with MSG just put a
little bit of [ __ ] lemon juice in
anything and and lemon juice enhances
everything especially vegetables it's
gonna excuse me fruit fruit with sugar
like
you're making [ __ ] Strawberry
Shortcake you put the damn cook some
sugar and some strawberries together and
put a little bit of lemon and taste it
you go that's okay put a little bit of
lemon in it and then taste it oh yeah
that's really good
that's another flavor enhancer that's
what MSG was like that just it was just
dry okay Jim all right I'm done Tom's
sake said the attic episode was the one
with a Dead junkie in the basement and
the daughter reconciles with her father
we did watch that one recently that is
actually like a pretty good it's pretty
good I think that was one of the ones
that we watched we watched like two or
three of them in a row like deciding
which one to do and that wasn't the one
we decided on but I don't think we ever
did a show on that Victor says MSG made
me gay yeah yeah MHC will make you gay
now I will say that back in the 90s when
I was eating a lot of ramen noodles
because I was like really poor well I'm
still really poor but when I was even
poorer than I am now
um and I had migraines like all the time
and I didn't know why and then I said
something to my mom and she was like oh
well maybe it's because you eat all
those ramen noodles and there's like MSG
in there but I don't know if that's what
was causing it but I don't really have
um migraines anymore or headaches so it
was MSG was rumored to cause headaches
and Caucasians it did it didn't have
that effect in Japanese people
well I don't think maybe maybe there's a
chance maybe I mean I had bad bad
migraines and it's like I very very
rarely have headaches rarely anymore
chemist looked at it and said this is
basically modified salt it shouldn't
[ __ ] right but I mean some people
might still have everybody's different
so some people might have different
sensitivity you see it than others or
allergies or something like that maybe I
had some kind of allergy to it I don't
know
I haven't had problems since then but
I'm just saying I was eating a lot of
ramen noodles at that time because like
I said I was broke so then I had and I
had migraines like pretty much every day
which I don't have anymore and haven't
for many years
because the thing about it now is when I
I still eat ramen noodles but I don't
use the packet you know after I stopped
using the packet I stopped having
migraines okay but that's I've realized
that that is that's anecdotal effort
I've been giving you the packets
have you yeah package in it with creamer
and cream and cheese and yeah maybe I
got maybe I got over it or maybe it was
something else causing it yeah no
because I've been giving you the packets
when I would give you Ramen because I
don't know what was causing it back then
that's not that I'm not having it now I
remember eating MSG as a little kid and
just [ __ ] loving it
I might have had a headache but maybe
you get over it you might get it you
know what I mean [ __ ] I don't
remember it you know
I don't remember having headaches every
time I ate
MSG that was back in the 70s man well
that's what I mean in the 70s
maybe everybody's walking around with
migraines all the time you just got it
could be a lot of [ __ ] to your eating
has MSG in it and they don't say
anything
well it's just I mean that's kind of
true of everything right like there's
always a lot of things have MSG in it
that you don't know how that mystery in
it yeah just like a lot of things have
sugar in it a lot of things have
different things in it insect particles
well yeah but anything red is made out
of damn [ __ ] beetle carapace
yeah pretty much yeah
that's okay though yeah I mean you know
what are you gonna do
it it won't hurt you yeah Tom Sykes says
spices always affect Caucasian people
which makes me think Christopher
Columbus was a lie that white people
were searching for spices
maybe that's what it was yeah I don't
have problems with like a lot of spices
but for some reason I did have a lot of
migraines back when I was eating a lot
of ramen noodles there's a lot of
stereotypes that [ __ ] white people
don't like things that are hot and [ __ ]
I [ __ ] love well I think that's more
a Midwestern North yeah than uh than an
American stereo right
with their eating [ __ ] Scandinavian
based foods like [ __ ] eating Flemish
food and Danish food it's like [ __ ]
at the smorgasbord where there's no
spices at all that's like old people
it's old people they're all dead I think
I've used to remember I remember being a
kid where they were [ __ ] you'd run
into [ __ ] people
that would just [ __ ] put black pepper
on something go oh it's so hot oh and
like what or even like paprika and I'm
like paprika yeah paprika is not hot but
looking back on it they were like my
grandparents age yeah back then they
couldn't handle it it couldn't be
they didn't have spices because they
were poor they weren't used to that
well and that one came out of cans that
was like
yeah
I don't even think that's what it is
they were eat they ate they lived out of
cans eating canned food and there was
very little spice so everything kind of
tasted like a can yeah and anything that
was like
had any kind of flavor to it was just
overwhelming to them you know because
they were they came from poverty
which is hilarious to me I did I did
remember seeing one thing where somebody
was talking about how spicy something
was that just had like a little bit of
paprika on it I was like dude I can't
even like taste paprika yeah I mean
paprika is good but it's like it's not
spicy it doesn't really spicy it's just
um uh red bell pepper
um turned into baked and turned into
powder that's all it is no I mean the
thing about it is that like I don't like
super super spicy food like I don't want
you know the inside of my mouth to be
numb so I can't even taste the [ __ ] but
you know I don't want to endure my food
but so I don't like super spicy stuff
either but I like a little bit I Like It
Hot I like it spicy over the Indian food
Mexican food I like all that
it's Gotta Have flavor to it to me
Victor said my old boss sent back a
chicken fried steak because she said the
pepper and the breading was too small
I mean if you're thinking like black
Peppers too I'm baby I mean unless the
thing is coated with black pepper that's
okay but you know just a little bit of
pepper I don't I don't see like that's
not that's not anything
all right so let's finally talk about
this because we still have two more
cases and we're gonna be [ __ ] you
know we're already at two hours so we
need to get this show on the road
so okay so this happened in the late
1980s late 1988. so you got Jackie
Hernandez
and she seems even though she was older
than uh you know quite a bit older than
your classic Poltergeist Focus I guess
but she kind of had a lot of the things
going on that would normally make you a
poltergeist Focus you know what I mean
um she just had a really really bad uh
divorce a really bad breakup from her
husband
uh she was she had a two-year-old son
and was pregnant with another baby and
she was you know broke like so she was
in a really bad like financial situation
uh so she ends up moving into this
really little house in San Pedro
California which I think is still there
if I'm not mistaken
you know kind of hoping to get her life
back together or whatever
now
um shortly after moving into this house
though
she starts hearing weird noises up in
the attic
um she said that it sounded like people
were like talking and moving around up
there
she also saw some object movement like
she would see pencils uh she
specifically said she saw a bunch of
pencils like shooting out of a pencil
holder like by themselves
um you know just you know cans of soda
stuff like that like flying across the
room
um she had a bed uh fall apart like for
no reason
uh she also said that she saw a glowing
Cloud that she said tried to suffocate
her so there was that
which is kind of like your Blue Mist
thing that you saw
and
um this was kind of a big deal too she
said her and her friend
said that they also saw this weird like
thick substance coming out of the
kitchen wall
like it was just this kind of like weird
thick
I saw the reenactments it kind of looked
like I don't know like corn syrup or
something like that like it looked like
didn't look like blood or nothing that I
remember it kind of looked more like
corn syrup or like motor oil or
something like that
um and they also found like some
unexplained puddles which again that's
another kind of like Poltergeist kind of
thing but they leave like puddles of
things everywhere
so her baby is born and not too long
after that
Jackie starts having
the same nightmare over and over
in this nightmare she took on the
identity of a young guy who was being
murdered near San Pedro Harbor
and right around this time also she
started seeing a like an apparition of
like an old guy in the house she said
she would see him like he was either
sitting at the dining room table or he
was sitting on the edge of her son's bed
and she said she saw him on multiple
occasions like a scary old man
now eventually
um Jackie had this neighbor who was also
a friend of hers named Susan Castaneda
and I guess Susan Castaneda like somehow
knew Dr Berry Taff
um like I said he was also like a
researcher on the Doris bitter case
which was the basis of The Entity
so in August of 1989 Dr Taff shows up to
the San Pedro house to see what's going
on
so he comes there with two photographers
Barry Conrad and Jeff wheatcraft were
their names
so they go into this little bitty house
um and the first thing that Dr Taft said
he noticed was there was a really really
bad smell in the house like Rotting
Flesh again very very common with this
kind of thing yeah I gotta say something
though okay what are you gonna say
I was in a conversation with with with
with Barry
uh online
he said part of the smell wasn't part of
the smell was that or at least part of
it came from the fact that this woman
[ __ ] didn't throw garbage out her
[ __ ] that place was filthy yeah they
did say that they I because I think that
he said when he first went in there like
he was trying to be diplomatic but he's
like yeah I kind of feel like this would
probably be condemned yeah almost like
uh almost like a hoarder house like it
was a [ __ ] yeah she wouldn't throw
garbage away or anything
which yeah so that might have been the
pungent stage I don't think that
anything to do with like Paranormal
stuff
um that might have just been because she
was like you said I don't know if she
was
I don't know if they uh if I'd call it a
hoarder because I have seen like video
of this situation and it doesn't look
like a hoarder but it's not like a it's
a tiny little house
um and it kind of looked like she didn't
really like clean it or anything and she
was a loon she was a lunatic a little
bit yeah a little bit he said she was
mentally not there
which I mean you could read that both
ways if you want to think that like
Poltergeist and [ __ ] like that are real
then you could say well maybe that was
like encouraging it yeah or she created
it or she oh yeah that's amazing
but he said she was a lunatic
yeah well what are you gonna do I don't
doubt it yeah I think well you know
what's weird is I think the same thing
happened in the Doris bither case like
when he went over to that house I think
that house was kind of like a [ __ ]
too yeah I don't think it was as bad as
this one but
you know she was mentally disorganized
yeah
there's a lot of pressure
and stress too
which you know I get it I mean she has a
two-year-old kid and a baby yeah and
doesn't have any money right it's just
like you know that's a very very
stressful situation to be in I can't
imagine
so um
yeah so they come in and it's kind of
like like I said a little bit of a
[ __ ]
so Dr Taft starts questioning Jackie and
while he's in the process of doing that
um they all heard a really loud bang
coming from the attic and then like
another louder bang uh coming from the
same place
now
they were like hey what was that Jackie
says oh that's
um
she said that banging noise is caused by
a floating severed head
uh that she'd seen up there on several
occasions prior to the arrival of Dr
Taff that's creepy so the severed head
is floating around up in the attic like
banging into the walls apparently
or it the head floats around and makes
things [ __ ] move
although it's funnier to me thinking
about the head just going boom whoops
maybe maybe the head is nearsighted I
think she just saw a disembodied face up
there
and heard a bunch of noise that's pretty
weird thinking that there's like a
disembodied head floating around your
[ __ ] attic I don't like that not one
bit
but if they put that in the movie
everybody would laugh I know this case I
think this case did happen I'm not I'm
making fun of it but I think it did
happen
we make fun of everything that's kind of
our thing yeah even if even if we like
it yeah
El padrino said was this from the movie
The Entity yes um no it's not no
no yeah this is the one about the woman
I know no it's not okay look she's
getting mad at me again no it's not I
told you yeah but because I've said it
multiple times
I said it's the same dot it's the same
parapsychologist but this is a different
case that was that was Doris bither this
is Jackie Hernandez Oh I thought we were
talking about Doris busy no we did a
show about George Smith or a long time
ago all right okay I thought we were
talking about no I said Jackie okay so
then I gotta back up the smell thing was
attributed to [ __ ] Doris bither the
one from The Entity case yeah all right
so I don't he said that she didn't clean
her house
that he was [ __ ] filled with garbage
dude she said this one was filled with
garbage too no okay then okay then then
then my comments I was talking about
Doris oh okay we'll see now I'm confused
because it's like I thought you were
talking about this case no well I
thought well I thought I thought we were
talking about Dora Spitzer no I told you
multiple times because Doris beather
also had some [ __ ] happening up in the
attic
from The Entity case
I mean they are similar but I thought
that's what we talked about didn't that
was yeah we're [ __ ] they went there
take pictures in the dab electrical cord
went around dude's neck no that's this
case then I'm then I'm conflating two
different yeah you are okay that's what
I'm saying that's this case that's not
the entity I don't even think Doris
bether had an attic in her house unless
I'm remembering it wrong all right okay
I don't remember anything I don't
remember any attic [ __ ] happening okay
yeah and Tom Sykes said this case is
very similar like yeah it is but you
know I'm just saying it's not
don't listen to her don't listen to me
listener
why why don't listen to me you're you're
the one I'm just trying to put it you're
the one that [ __ ] it up
you're the one that's confused
so yeah alcohol just Booth yeah it's
obviously yeah so yeah floating severed
head banging into the walls yeah causing
some banging which like I said is kind
of funny but then like if that was
really happening to you it wouldn't be
funny at all I feel like because that's
like pretty creepy
so um on this first visit actually Dr
Taft went into the kitchen and took some
samples of the weird fluid that was uh
oozing out the walls
and he was actually he said that he was
there when some more of the liquid like
seeped out like from uh from the by the
kitchen cabinets so he did say that he
saw it so I guess it wasn't fake or if
it wasn't they did a really good job of
it
now they analyzed this is weird so they
analyzed this substance
and they found out
allegedly that it was blood plasma yeah
I remember that belonging to a man hmm
now Jackie said she had no idea where it
could have come from
like I said I don't know if this is true
or not it's the same case where they got
the pictures of the little orbs and
little balls [ __ ] down at the [ __ ]
uh I don't know if it meets the floor I
thought that was Doris bitter but
I know it was I know it was it was
Taft's case
like I said I got two of them so do you
know yeah because remember they had the
they were taking pictures of little
light balls
was it this one
um maybe I don't I don't really
uh Tom Sykes said the the bitter case
had Spirit rape and this one didn't yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah Dora spither said
she got raped by what three different or
or there was like two that would hold
her down and then like the other one
that was the door that was Doris bitter
I don't think any of that went on with
Jackie Hernandez though
but yeah so uh blood plasma seeping out
of your kitchen walls that's a little
bit weird
is that allegedly I don't know that's
that's just what it says
so they were there for the rest of the
afternoon and like nothing happened like
for the rest of the afternoon but then
like after it got dark Jeff and Barry
the two photographers who were on the
team they decide they're gonna go up in
the attic
um and they're gonna take a couple more
pictures up there
so while they were up there
um Jeff said that his camera got
snatched out of his hands and like flung
across the room
and then something that he couldn't see
like shoved him
and he also said that he got like uh you
know
that he was like really really like
freaked out by this but I guess that was
like the last thing that happened that
particular night but like worst [ __ ]
happened like later on
so for the next couple weeks because the
the team were not staying there they
just kind of came there to investigate
and they said yeah that's like some
weird [ __ ] like you know call us if
something else happens so for a couple
of weeks like nothing happened like they
didn't hear from her like from Jackie
Hernandez
but then on September 4th and I believe
this is still 1988. Barry Conrad the
photographer he gets a phone call from
her and she says you need to come out
here like right now because the [ __ ] is
getting like really really bad and it's
like unlivable
so Barry calls Jeff the other
photographer and called another
researcher that was on the team whose
name was Gary and then all three of them
like went to San Pedro with all of their
equipment
now once they get there
um they said that they saw and maybe
this is what you were thinking of they
said they saw like these weird like
balls of light and they were floating
through the rooms and going through the
walls yeah
now
um like in the entity case you remember
the entity case where they took the
pictures of like the of the light arcs
and all that kind of stuff
um they said similar to that they
weren't as dramatic as the K as the
pictures from that case but they did get
some of the some of them on film like I
said it's not as dramatic as the bitter
ones but they did still get some of the
orbs and like weird lights and stuff
I did that Jeff was like we should go
back to up to the attic because that
seemed to be work like where a lot of
the activity was going on
so Jeff and Gary
um go up to the attic and they were just
kind of like taking pictures around like
not taking pictures of anything in
particular just kind of taking pictures
of whatever
and so nothing was really happening so
they're like well I guess we'll just go
back downstairs but while they're about
to go back downstairs Jeff
um apparently like he just kind of like
sucked in his breath like oh my God like
that now the attic was like really
really dark but Gary turned around and
just like took a picture like he
couldn't see what he was taking a
picture of but he just did it like
instinctively
so this is the very very famous picture
that shows Jeff
it looks like he's hanging from a nail
on a ceiling rafter like by his neck
like he's way up in the air like you've
ever seen a picture his head is like
that it's a very very famous picture
like in paranormal circles
evidently it was just a big disturbance
and dude took a picture real quick and
that's what he caught but yeah because
he couldn't really see yeah he wasn't up
there for long
evidently
and the dude said he didn't even know
what happened as it was over before he
knew it I mean it's an interesting
photograph could it have been fake yeah
yeah they could have faked it but
that's the photo they got yeah
so a couple minutes later
um you know Jeff got down and he went
downstairs and he said like from his
experience he's like I was only a couple
of steps behind Gary
um and we were kind of starting to come
down from the attic but that in the
darkness like I said I couldn't really
see
he said that he felt like a noose had
been thrown around his neck and he'd
been forcefully yanked back and then
upwards yeah
um now when he got thank you Aaron E
gonna catch the show tomorrow to make my
work day better but want to stop by and
say happy new year happy New Year to you
and thank you very much hopefully you
enjoy it tomorrow we went off on all
kinds of crazy tangents yeah so it was
like so you've got something to look
forward to that's super fun
so uh so yeah so they look at his neck
when they get down there
and he still apparently had some
clothesline or something like that like
tied around his neck and he had like all
these red marks like where the Rope had
like yanked it you know what I mean
um and after that like probably not
surprisingly Jeff was like yeah not
going back there I don't think I'm gonna
go back to that house no thank you uh so
he never went back which you know you
can't blame the guy
so after this incident
um the phenomena kind of seemed to chill
out a little bit now Jackie said that
she still saw the weird lights or orbs
or whatever uh she said she still heard
like banging sounds and like weird
voices or mumbling from the attic from
time to time and uh still smelled that
horrible smell that smelled like rotting
meat or whatever
but it wasn't quite at the level that it
had been prior to that
now a few months later Jackie and her
ex-husband kind of got back together and
she moved back in with him and this was
about 300 miles away from the house
where she'd been living in San Pedro
so for a while while all that was going
on
um obviously she reported no Paranormal
Activity because I guess everything was
fine
but um you know this is her ex-husband
for a reason so they were together all
that long before [ __ ] started going
sideways once again and uh you know they
broke up again so the Paranormal [ __ ]
starts happening again
now at the house that she was sharing
with her then with her ex-husband
um she started hearing banging noises
coming from a shed in the backyard
and also her and the neighbors said that
they saw the same Apparition of the old
guy
that had been at the San Pedro house
um showing up on a TV screen in this
house wait a minute hold on and that was
300 miles away they saw who appear it
was the old man The Apparition remember
I said about it yeah no you don't
remember
no the old man the old man that was
sitting at the dining room table or okay
on the on the son's bed or whatever yeah
that they saw him on TV yeah
in the house 300 miles away hmm
so they saw him in a reflection on
allegedly on a TV that was turned off or
the TV that was I'm not really sure what
are they talking about I assumed that it
was that they saw him in a TV that was
off like a reflection a reflection of it
that's what I assumed but I could be
wrong about that because yeah you're
right that is an ambiguous yeah I don't
know exactly it's like what was he
showing up on TV like reading the
[ __ ] weather or what you know
inside the cathode ray tube along with
the [ __ ] uh you know [ __ ] all the
other dudes from videodrome or whatever
[ __ ] you know that was what are we
talking about he's like hey I'm gonna
ghost I followed you what's up
[Laughter]
because there's been other cases where
they see somebody in the reflection of
an old for you guys they're too that
happens a lot on a haunting yeah for you
guys that are too young to know what a
real television look like the old
television was a dab glass like a blown
glass ball you know basically it's real
shiny when it was off you could get a
reflection out of it almost like a
mirror like a Black Mirror that's kind
of cool or a gray mirror really well
Black Mirror is a TV show so but you
can't you can't do that with these new
[ __ ] screens you have today but back
in those days you could get a reflection
of something in a room in it off of it
so I didn't know if that's what they
were talking about because
basically it must be I wasn't sure
either because everything just kind of
says they saw him on a TV screen I'm
like well yeah that could mean a lot of
things yeah I mean not like it matters
all that much but I'm just saying that
it's still like kind of weird
Tom Sykes said too bad there's not a
sand pager a haunting movie I'm actually
surprised they haven't made a movie
about this I've seen like a couple
documentaries about it but I don't think
they've made like a fictional
movie about it but it's weird because it
would be a good The Entity had a lot of
[ __ ] nudity in it see so that's why
they made that movie well yeah they're
like ghost rape oh my God sign us up you
see the titties of [ __ ] moving now
I'm gonna say I like the movie The
Entity it's good but the end of that is
ridiculous yeah and it's kind of based
on what somebody said that they were
trying it's not based on what actually
happened no it's not based on what
happened it's based on what was said
they were talking about maybe we should
catch this thing and they're gonna
freeze it yeah so they go they go in
this movie we are gonna catch this thing
go sickles and we're gonna freeze it
yeah because that'll work all I could
think of was like little ghost popsicles
I loved it when I was a kid though I was
like I still love that movie yeah like
okay but like I said the end of it we're
gonna catch this ghost we're gonna
[ __ ] freeze it liquid nitrogen yeah
and where are these paranormal it's like
investigators got a [ __ ] whole
laboratory with liquid well didn't they
build wait a minute
well they didn't they build inside the
laboratory it's been a while since I've
seen the movie but didn't they build
inside the laboratory like a whole fake
house like yeah like a mock-up of her
bedroom to lure the the rapey ghost
there so they could get them and they're
like Boo [ __ ] we're never gonna freeze
you yeah it had a fantasy ending which
is a ridiculous concept it looked good
on screen though it's ridiculous yeah
that's right the scientists will fix it
with all their endless money
sure yes American thinking like you'd
really get a grant to do that yeah
you would not well I had to compete
against [ __ ] Close Encounters of the
Third Kind and all the other [ __ ] that
was going on
I mean you think ghost rape would be
enough for to get people to watch it we
don't need Frozen ghosts all of science
has taken this seriously they've pooled
in their money to make a whole ghost
capture [ __ ]
underground cave with [ __ ] it looked
like it was in an underground [ __ ]
bunker to be honest I'm gonna say that
the that the whatever technology that
they came up with in Ghostbusters yeah
like the stuff that just like sucked the
proton pack yeah where you sucked him
into the Trap was a lot more believable
right then and freezing freezing ghosts
with liquid nitrogen yeah that is an
outlandish proposition that's all they
could come up with
I mean I'm talking like it's like you
know maybe that works I don't know the
proton the proton pack is a better idea
ghosts one weakness yeah liquid suction
closes up see that to me that makes a
lot more sense then you got it on the
end of a wire and it looks all heavy
duty it's got emergency and then they
put it in the bigger storage facility
Yellow emergency and then the storage
facility eventually but it's like a like
a nuclear meltdown yeah you know so it
has like um I mean that has kind of like
equivalence in real life so it kind of
like makes like I said you put them all
in a because they put them all in the
storage facility and then the storage
facility like started to leak
essentially or like blew up and that's
what released all the ghosts right so
like I said like a nuclear meltdown so
we have like a real life equivalent of
that so it was a lot more believable I
just don't really get I don't know who
came up with the idea of like let's have
Frozen ghosts at the end
I wouldn't worry about it
they they worry they made that [ __ ] up
on the drop of a hat how do we catch a
ghost we're just free you freeze it you
freeze it you freeze that's that's
that's 50 stinking and they were all
sitting around like smoking a dude
it's 19. yeah that'll work yeah and then
it busts out of the ice boom but I mean
I mean that movie came out in 1978
though I think yeah the dudes that wrote
that came out of the 50s probably that's
like some [ __ ] yeah like the blue thing
Frozen you freeze it like the blob maybe
that's what they were thinking they were
thinking of The Blob but like I said it
makes sense more with The Blob because
the blob is like a thing it's like a
it's a it's a corporeal these
[ __ ] I can't think outside the
[ __ ] it's like a big jujube or like
outside this normal space-time Continuum
they're thinking about an object see
ghosts must be an object or it wouldn't
be real
and you know then on Ghostbusters
they're going to take it a little bit
[ __ ] further they're gonna see
because that was 80.
they're gonna go well
um it doesn't have to be solid to be
real okay because magnetism is real so
there's an electromagnetic field that's
real and you can't see it okay you can't
hold which like I said that makes more
sense so because it's all of the same
it's you know so we're only using
electromagnetic field sure it's the
ghost that makes the amount of protons
whatever a proton is that's what they're
saying an atomic [ __ ] yeah yeah that'll
work we'll just suck it in there yeah
yeah it'll have lightning see I buy that
lightning bolts and wind yeah I mean I
mean I know it's not real I'm just
saying I buy that more I'm just like all
right I'll allow it yeah electric
magnetism Frozen ghosts I'm not allowing
Atomic electromagnetism can can capture
the ghost that's what they're saying
because all I can think of like at the
end because the thing about the the
thing about the entity was that the
movie was like it was so good and like
so serious like up to then and then I
was just like at the end of it it's like
all I could imagine yeah do you know
what I am I want that movie now do you
know what I imagined do you know um you
know when you used to go to the ice
cream truck and they had the the ice
cream bars that kind of look like Mickey
Mouse's head except like if he was
melting yeah yeah or if he had some
poorly poorly
like they were kind of like scary
looking yeah that's what I thought I
thought of like a ghost on the end of
like a stick like an ice cream that's
what I thought of and I'm like that's
probably not the association that you
want with your serious horror movie
Ghostbusters but it's a good movie
otherwise Ghostbusters had it better you
catch it inside an electromagnetic field
and now you got it in a basically a
metal shoe box that has a wire on it and
then you can stuff that into a Mainframe
and download them in there
just like a [ __ ] computer cartridge
for your video game yeah see that makes
and now he's in there yeah he's in there
now electromagnetically he's because
it's information yeah you know what I
mean that makes a lot more it made more
sense to the mind of the 80s person
right you're like that's why people
thought that that's why people bought
that yeah honestly I saw They just added
Ghostbusters on who's that HBO Max it
was some like streaming service that I
have and I was like oh my God I kind of
want to watch even though I've seen that
movie so many times I've like memorized
it Ghostbusters is so [ __ ] great
that's actually one of my favorite
comedies of all time I think
I saw that in the theater it's a good
movie it's still fun it's still funny
part two is good
yeah I actually part three but I don't
think I remember it
um wasn't there part three or just two
at least I don't think they made a point
they did a remake but or not no it
wasn't a remake they did an all-girl
remake well no then they did one like
more recently that was Ghostbusters
afterlife yeah
people say it was okay it's pretty good
I actually kind of wanted to see it
um you know the trailers looked all
right and they had like a lot of the you
know a lot of the original guys are dead
you know sadly but you know what I mean
but I liked the idea of doing that they
didn't revive that they didn't revive
that franchise in time
see yeah it was like um they should have
done that they should they should have
brought those guys back in the 90s and
that would be well they all still looked
well they all still look about this okay
well they were also alive they were all
alive and they would have been fit
enough to abuse [ __ ] they should have
had that [ __ ] in 91 or 92. and you have
a [ __ ] badass [ __ ] Ghostbusters
flick well they were probably thinking
about it but you know they were thinking
they were doing other [ __ ] happens [ __ ]
happens right
so uh so yeah Jeffy art said so they
captured ghosts to make good humor
Pac-Man popsicles yeah that's that's
what I thought of like I said it's
probably not the association that you
want but um yeah
so um
so Jackie and her husband yeah they get
back together we got distracted by uh
the old man appearing on the TV screen
we were trying to decide if it was just
a reflection or if he was actually on TV
so um
so she calls uh the team back and says
hey uh you know paranormal [ __ ] is also
happening here at this house that I'm at
now 300 miles away
so the two like very Taft didn't go but
the two other guys on the team uh Jeff
and Barry they went to the new house to
kind of see what was going on now they
said that as soon as they got to the new
house their equipment started going
crazy like it was just turning off and
on randomly and like break in and chill
like that
so they decide they're going to set up a
seance because why not
so they put down the Ouija board they do
all that stuff which like I said that's
always a mistake
and they start asking questions of
whatever this entity was
so this entity supposedly said that it
was an 18 year old man who had been
murdered near San Pedro Harbor in 1930.
and they asked him it's like hey why did
you [ __ ] with Jeff like trying to hang
him or whatever the [ __ ] it was you did
uh the guy on the Ouija board the ghost
said oh well Jeff look like the guy who
killed me yeah so I was like trying to
get back at him I'm like I think some
people are like pushing the plan [ __ ]
just saying like trying to get that
[ __ ] dancing [ __ ] to me yeah that
does sound like [ __ ]
so now at this point apparently during
the Seance Jeff again uh gets thrown
against the wall and was knocked out so
the ghost really hates Jeff
is what I'm saying he really does not
like Jeff
now Jeff wakes up and he says that he
felt like he was being strangled and
then the ghost threw him against the
wall again because the ghost is a giant
douche
so they they were like okay well that's
enough seance for today uh so they just
like stopped it and uh never continued
because like I said it's always a bad
idea
now Jackie did some research on her own
and later discovered that the body of a
man named Herman Hendrickson was indeed
found floating in San Pedro Harbor in
1930. although the man was actually 28
not 18 at the time that he died and also
uh at the time that he died uh his death
had been ruled in accidental drowning
not suspected as a murder doesn't mean
it wasn't a murder it just wasn't
expected it means that they didn't
suspect that it was a murder that he
probably died from drowning I mean it
was 1930 what the [ __ ] did they know
nothing
now uh Jackie also said that the old guy
that she said that she had seen in the
San Pedro house and also on the TV in
the new house
was she figured out that it was the
spirit of the builder of the house he
was a guy named John Damon
I don't know she said that the reason
she came to this conclusion which again
sounds a little bit like [ __ ]
was that she had once followed one of
the mystery you know the mysterious
balls of light she was saying all the
time that she followed one of those into
a cemetery and the ball of light hovered
over that guy's grave and that's how she
figured it out I thought it was going to
be like on a haunting where they were
like looking through some old records
and like oh my God that's the ghost I
saw like a picture of an old dude from
that but I don't think that was the case
I think she was just like oh I followed
a light and it hovered over Graven so
yeah
um so Dr Barry Taff
he um did not think that uh whatever
Jackie's problems were were caused by
ghosts as in spirits of the Dead
just as in the entity case he seemed to
believe that it was Poltergeist activity
he thought that because of Jackie's a
very unstable mental state in her High
state of stress at the time
had kind of caused her to become a
poltergeist Focus wittingly or
unwittingly
um you know she'd just been through a
really bad divorce uh you know she was
very poor she had two very young
children she was under a lot of stress
um you know and she maybe wasn't all
that together I don't really know
um Dr Taff also seemed to think that
Jackie had a bit of a crush on Barry one
of the photographers
and was unconsciously attacking Jeff the
other photographer because she thought
that he was in the way of her getting
the other man I don't know if that's
true or not but Taft thought that was
his perception or at least that's what I
read that this that that's what his
perception was so that's kind of like
what he was thinking he's like maybe
that's why the entity or whatever it was
like attacked Jeff specifically like all
the time because of her like she was mad
at him that's why that was the reason he
came up with her being mad at him I
don't know
so uh Jackie moved around a few times
and I think the entity supposedly like
followed her several times
um but eventually uh it did leave her
alone and uh she moved to Los Angeles at
some point I'm not actually sure I
haven't heard much about her in the last
few years so I don't know if she's still
alive or not
um I had heard that I thought I'd heard
that she died but I could be wrong about
that
um and I've also heard that other people
that live in the original House in San
Pedro which is still there it's been
fixed up like it doesn't look like a
dump or anything like that
um that they've also heard where doors
is coming noises coming from the attic
but I don't know if that's true or not
but you know that might just be rumors
but I have heard that
so the last case we want to talk about
uh today
is the South Shields Poltergeist do you
remember this case yeah I read I have
the book this is I read 2005. yeah read
the book yeah I was impressed with the
book I liked it some crazy [ __ ] happened
in this one too yeah
and I was like man that's one of the
best Poltergeist cases I ever heard of
but then I was talking to Steve mayor
about it and he goes yeah but then he
goes look at here look at this and look
at that and I was going oh yeah there's
problems with this case
probably I I mean there's kind of it's
an interesting case it is well they're
all interesting but
I find them interesting from like a a
ghost story point of view yeah I don't
necessarily believe a lot there's a
chance this one could be faked
oh man you you could find good
Poltergeist cases and and copy make a
good Poltergeist Case by copying that
one they may have done that with this
but we'll see
yeah that's you know
all right
so
now the thing about this one is that I
guess the couple at the center of this
didn't really want any uh publicity or
to be made fun of or anything like that
so they've seems like they've managed to
keep their real names uh Under Wraps
so usually whenever anybody talks about
this case I don't see a lot of stuff
online about this case to be honest with
you
uh but they're usually just referred to
as Mark and Marianne that's you know
nobody knows what their real names I'm
sure somebody knows but I don't know
so this couple like I said this happened
in 2005. and this was in uh England
so they were in their 20s uh at the time
that this occurred and they had a
three-year-old son whose name was Robert
now they had lived in this uh it was a
Terrace House in uh South Shields
England which is kind of like a Seaside
town
uh they'd lived there for quite a long
time
with absolutely nothing weird happening
at all
um but then in December of 2005 all kind
of weird [ __ ] started happen for some
reason
so at first it kind of started small as
usual uh doors opening and closing on
their own
um objects turning up in places where
they shouldn't have been like you know
going missing from one place and popping
up somewhere you get where they were
supposed to be
also uh bad cold spots and weird banging
sounds coming out of the walls
so you know this is pretty upsetting but
um they weren't really all that alarmed
about it I guess it wasn't like constant
or anything like that
now one of the first things that like
really freaks them out like this had
been going on for a while and it was
like pretty creepy but one of the first
things that really freaked him out was
uh Mark and Marianne came home one
evening
and found that in the kitchen
two chairs uh had been stacked on top of
the kitchen table like and obviously
nobody that's very very Poltergeist
um you know where the chairs kind of
like uh arrange themselves into a weird
configuration so they had that kind of
thing happen which yeah that'd be a
little freaky if you walked into saw
that
um also one night they came home and
found that a very heavy like uh dresser
or like a chest of drawers had moved
into a total other bedroom all by itself
so it kind of like teleported yeah like
you said so you know there was there was
that so again that would be pretty weird
now from the night that they saw the
dresser move they didn't see it move
they just saw that it was in a different
place
and that seemed to be like kind of the
kicking off point for all of it because
all kind of crazy [ __ ] started happening
after that
um one night a couple nights later Mark
and Marianne are getting into bed all of
a sudden Marianne feels something hit
her in the head
so she looks around like what the [ __ ]
was that and it was one of her the sons
like um toy dogs he had like a little
stuffed toy dog and it was one of those
and he's like well that was in Robert's
room obviously and their kid was also in
his room sleeping so Marianne couldn't
figure out like how this dog like where
it could have come from you know what I
mean like she hadn't seen it in there
before
so she's sitting there like thinking
about it and then another one of the
kids toys another toy dog comes flying
through the room and hit her again like
much harder this time like something had
been like something had thrown it was
just a stuffed animal but it like hit
her like really hard like something had
thrown it really hard
so the two of them are just like
completely mystified
and then a couple of moments after that
they said it was just completely like
pelted with stuffed animals from their
son's room and they couldn't figure out
where they were coming from they said it
kind of looked like they were just
coming out of midair you know what I
mean like they were just appearing and
like hitting them you know what I mean
yeah it's kind of and they were coming
from like every direction it was kind of
why when I was reading this book I was
like man this sounds like the real
[ __ ] thing because it was similar to
what happened to me at Mammoth Mountain
the way it was described in this book
this is kind of way it really seems
but
you could have still faked it
you can still fake because you're just
writing a book well yeah I mean I can
wake up all kinds of things like if
nobody else was there seeing it but me
that's right if you know but if you have
good sources on what a real case looks
like you know what to write yeah and
that's kind of what
Steve said about this case because
there's some [ __ ] that happens in the
actual case it doesn't jive up like a
table [ __ ] gets partially melted and
then returns to normal but they didn't
take a picture of it in the Melton state
which that was something that a good
investigator would have done is
immediately taken a picture well that's
something that most people would do like
especially nowadays that everybody has a
cell phone like you would just you'd be
like holy [ __ ] look at that yeah and it
was sending text messages and stuff but
we don't get any photographs of the
[ __ ] texts or we don't we don't have
any data on that so
I mean the story is really good to be
fair this was 2005. like I kind of like
people didn't have like smartphones like
they have now so it's like a lot of
phones didn't have well 2005 like did
phones have they had photo capability
but I think they just took like really
really shitty photos did they not I
can't really I think they were okay I
can't really remember I think they were
okay I mean 2005 was they weren't they
weren't HD but they were probably like
240 or 420 yeah they were like kind of
[ __ ] about like that
so I don't I don't really remember like
how good the photos were from phones but
they were in there with investigative
[ __ ] stuff and found you know 35
millimeter cameras and [ __ ]
you know and digital cameras so why did
they took pictures why didn't they take
a picture of that damn table that was
melted like I said you think if anything
you'd really want to take picture of
that or video ideally yeah so that's the
problem with this case not saying it's a
it's a false case
it's just that if they actually
investigated this case they didn't do a
very good job because they didn't get
pictures but they should have taken they
got pictures of other [ __ ] though
that's what I mean that's kind of what
makes me really skeptical about a lot of
these is that and especially ones that
happen nowadays because now there's no
excuse like because everybody has a
[ __ ] cell phone everybody has cameras
like everything's really cheap and
people are taking pictures of [ __ ] all
the time and it's like if this [ __ ] was
going on you'd think somebody somewhere
but see the thing about it too is that
nowadays it's also really really easy to
fake that [ __ ] too and like pretty much
anybody that has like a smartphone can
make something that looks like realistic
so that's another problem
like I said you know I
I can uh make pretty much anything you
want in Photoshop yeah give me an hour
and I'll make a picture of whatever you
want so um you know and most people can
do that nowadays so it's a lot harder to
because it's so much easier to like fake
photos and fake videos so it's
photos and videos aren't
um you know uh aren't proof anymore
really because everything's just [ __ ]
you can fake anything like really
quickly and really easily
so yeah so they're getting all these
stuffed animals thrown at them from
every direction
so I guess Mark and Marianne are trying
to like pull the blankets like over
their heads
um but then whatever the thing was they
said started kind of yanking on the
blank it's like trying to pull the the
comforter off of them
now while this was going on
Mark supposedly like uh screamed like he
was in pain or something and he said he
felt like something was burning him
so Marianne said she looked at the place
where he said the pain was and saw 13
which again that's a little fishy
because that's like ooh a scary number
um she saw like all these angry red
marks like uh like claw marks
essentially so 13 claw marks that's a
lot of claws just saying I don't know
how far apart they were
um so yeah so that happened and then
that was the last thing that happened
that night
um the next morning these 13 scratch
marks had allegedly disappeared which
convenient but you know what I mean
so from that point forward uh the
Poltergeist activity continued uh
usually utilizing Robert's toys and uh
various technological devices to kind of
[ __ ] with them
so you'd get stuff like stuffed toys
moving across the floor like by
themselves or making weird noises like
you know stuffed animals that weren't
supposed to make noises would be making
noises
um you know toys turning on and off like
by themselves
um very famously on one occasion a toy
bunny was found sitting at the top of
the stairs with a box cutter like in
between its paws which you know it
didn't come from the store like that
obviously
um another time Robert had this kind of
wooden rocking horse and they found it
hanging from a ceiling fan like by its
little reins or whatever
and um they also had [ __ ] happening like
the the sink or the toilet would look
like it filled up with blood or like
some kind of like red fluid obviously
um and then it would disappear a few
minutes later again convenient
um but you know I'm not being an [ __ ]
I'm just saying it's very convenient
now um
so as you mentioned before this
Poltergeist was very uh communicative
so it had so Robert their kid had this
magnetic drawing board thing
and so the Poltergeist apparently would
write [ __ ] on it
um and he would write [ __ ] like just go
now
R.I.P or die [ __ ] which that's nice so
GTFO says the ghost real real creative
yeah
yeah I'm like you're dead it's like
can't you think of anything better to do
it's like geez although other than like
[ __ ] with me that one girl that I
talked to
from Paranormal Witness
she sent me that damn I believe exactly
what happened that cat thing the cat
yeah and that's all that Poltergeist did
was write the word cat and I was like
that's it
that that that's full of God it's very
simple
they don't have verbal skills that's
coming from it's got to be coming from
like the left portion of the brain
it doesn't have very good
verbal skills that they can't write well
I thought that was the right portion or
is it the right proportion they don't
have doesn't have further but the left
was like the logic yeah I think it's
coming from the part that has to do with
spatial awareness
that's right that's right things to do
with it because evidently the language
isn't over there maybe the ghost just
really primitive maybe I just really
like cats it's not a ghost
um whatever it is it doesn't have the
ability it doesn't really have
the ability for any kind of complicated
speech or writing so
so hence die [ __ ] yeah die [ __ ] cat
go mine just wrote go
or the in this case it also you're dead
which I'm like right okay
yeah bring it so yeah uh Marianne said
that she also got death threats from
this entity via text message
so it's a technological ghost this was
2005 so you know what I mean
um so apparently they couldn't Trace
these particular text messages to
um any account that was you know real
uh and also Marianne said that she would
get calls on her cell phone from her
home phone number like the landline even
when there was nobody home so there was
that going on as well
so uh yeah so this went on for a while
and then uh the whatever it was starts
[ __ ] with the kit Robert he was three
I think
uh at one point they found Robert in his
room like all kind of swaddled up in his
blanket and there was a plastic table
like balancing on top of him
they found him like that and he looked
like they said when they found him like
his eyes were open but he seemed like he
was asleep like he was unresponsive you
know what I mean
um and at another time they actually uh
they lost the kid for a little while
like they didn't know where he was and
then they found him like crammed into
this little closet like he was again
like wrapped up real tight in his
blanket and he was just like stuffed in
a closet someplace and was like
unresponsive so that was happening uh
more than once
so at this point uh the two of them were
freaking out so they call it paranormal
investigators uh the two of them were
named Mike Hollowell and Darren ritzen
so they got to the house about six
months after the uh phenomena had
started
now
the investigators they said when they
first got there uh because of the things
that the family had described to them so
far they were very very skeptical
because they said this sounds like some
crazy [ __ ]
so you know but you got to be like kind
of like that you come in and you're just
like maybe these people are nuts I don't
really know so they were like kind of
were like yeah that's that's too much
um but apparently they reported later
like I said I don't know if this is true
or not but they reported later that uh
yeah as soon as we got there like some
weird [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened so like we
believed in them
so they both said that they saw a whole
bunch of crazy [ __ ] like happening in
this house they said that they saw doors
opening and closing by themselves they
said that they saw some of the kids toys
like moving around on their on their own
like by themselves they saw objects
levitating they saw lamps swinging back
and forth on the ceiling
um and they said that their equipment
was just like all [ __ ] [ __ ] up like
all the time like you know so it was
like batteries were draining like stuff
was going off and on it was just like
all kind of crazy
um they said that they had had uh knives
hurled at them like by some invisible
force or whatever been there done that
well yeah you had a knife thrown at you
yeah kind of not at me thrown at the
back door yeah
um they said they heard weird voices
coming from a baby monitor
and they said that they saw weird
messages
um that were like threats showing up on
pieces of paper
or on Robert's like little uh whiteboard
like his little thing that he had in his
room
um now again they didn't capture a lot
of the stuff on film which like I said
you know that's convenient
but uh they did actually take a few
pictures there are a couple of pictures
I think like floating around out there
that I've seen
um that kind of look like that have uh
kind of chairs like stacked on top table
like in kind of a crazy way that looks
like yeah it looked like Poltergeist
phenomena right it did like it's it's I
don't know if I'd call it a famous photo
but I've seen it like several times and
it does look pretty weird I don't you
know I'm not saying it could have been
fake kind of stuff ours would do I'm
just saying it could have been fixed
yeah anything could have been fake I got
pictures of what happened to us at
Mammoth and [ __ ] okay yes towels laying
there so what chair upside down so what
well it was impressive to us
you know I mean we were just
recording it you know yeah you're like
why the hell would we take a picture of
that long time ago well it's because
that [ __ ] we didn't do it you know
something else did it you know
yeah that's the thing if you don't have
the context for the photo like yeah we
just walked in a room and found it like
this you showed it to somebody else
they're like why the [ __ ] you take a
picture of that point yeah well you had
to be there you had to understand what
was going on right
Jeffy art says when a ghost tells
someone to die is it necessarily a
decent threat if the ghost killed
someone when the victims go seek
Vengeance on the original ghost
laughs
I don't know man it's like there's
probably all kind of like Ghost Protocol
that we're oh Ghost Protocol that was a
movie wasn't it but uh but yeah
so yeah so there is kind of like one
famous photo from this case which has
chairs like it kind of crazy angles and
[ __ ] like that
now both of the investigators also said
that they saw an apparition like uh
hanging out in the kids room like on
several occasions
now according to one of their
researchers Hollowell this whatever it
was looked like a big black figure like
a shot like a shadow kind of guy
according to this he didn't really what
recorded this I have a package delivered
down there that will probably you should
go and go check out the door then yeah
you should go look don't leave it on the
front [ __ ] it's my pull-up bar don't
leave it on the front porch overnight we
might stealing
even though nobody can see our front
door from the street but still
um but yeah so it's this big black
shadow figure with didn't really have
you couldn't really see a face he said
but he said that it you could tell that
it was evil you know what I mean like it
was this force field of like Menace like
coming off him
now apparently uh the investigator said
that this black shadow man uh once
attacked Mark in like while they were
watching and left really obvious claw
marks across his back and then the next
day the claw marks had vanished
so they actually did get this on film
but apparently the quality of the film
is not really all that impressive like
if you saw it and you didn't know what
you were looking at I don't think that
it would you be like what the [ __ ] am I
looking at you know what I mean
so
this is really weird and I guess this
happens like a lot of times but not too
long after all this like crazy violent
[ __ ] happened
uh the investigator said that
all of that [ __ ] happened and then like
literally a day or two later like
everything just stopped
and like nothing happened again and they
didn't ever find any explanation for it
and they didn't really find because like
I said this does sound like Poltergeist
[ __ ] but it doesn't
it doesn't really sound like there was a
focus as such I don't really know enough
about the actual people at the center of
it yeah they had a kid but the kid was
only three so you don't really hear too
much about three-year-old kids being
Poltergeist Focus but you do kind of
hear about like older people being
Poltergeist focused sometimes so maybe
that was the case in this because they
were only in their 20s so I don't know
maybe that's the case there like I said
they don't really want their real names
known
so I mean as far as I know this could be
a completely made up story and somebody
could just be saying yeah they don't
want their identities known because
they're afraid they're going to get made
fun of and so somebody just made it up
like it was like an ARG or something I
don't really know
but uh but yeah so they said that it
stopped just abruptly and they never
found any explanation for it
um so you know they
apparently according to the two
investigators though they're like hey we
went there like looking to kind of
debunk this whole [ __ ] because we
thought the claims they were making were
outlandish and we were like gonna prove
them wrong or whatever but we came away
being like yeah that [ __ ] is real
because we saw a bunch of stuff like
that
so shortly after the phenomena stopped
uh Mark and Marianne apparently were
like just sick of that [ __ ] so they
moved away from the area and as I said
their real names have actually never
been released to the public as far as I
know I mean unless somebody found out
and uh they seem to have been able to
keep it that way which is kind of
amazing uh in this in this era so that's
another thing that kind of makes me
suspect that maybe this is a made-up
story like from from start to finish
because you missed what I missed what
what made it what made it a [ __ ]
figure
um did you get a package yeah
I said the fact that Mark and Marianne
yeah have been able to keep their
identity secret yeah even to this day
I'm like that in this day and age that
seems a little suspicious maybe they
never existed who knows that's what I'm
saying I don't know I mean I they have
like you know the names of the
investigators and those are real people
so
I don't know it just does kind of sound
like maybe this was written initially as
like a fictional
no way of knowing not enough not enough
information that's what I'm saying and I
don't really know because I was talking
about why you were gone I was talking
about how a lot of the [ __ ] in this case
sounded like Poltergeist but there's no
there's no obvious like Poltergeist
Focus they had a kid but the kid was
three yeah not enough and I mean it's
entirely entirely possible that one of
them could have been a focus they were
just in their 20s as strong as this
thing was you're talking about somebody
13 to 15. but I mean I you know you you
have heard of cases where it's happened
with an older person though yeah but I
don't know if those are real but see
yeah and that's what I'm saying too it's
like I don't know enough about any of
these people to like speculate about
because you know in the case we were
talking about before about Jackie
Hernandez we were saying it's like yeah
she was older yeah but they still
thought that if it was a poltergeist
then she was the focus because she was
going through some [ __ ] up [ __ ] you
can do it when you're older it's just
that the the the you know the
the effects aren't as strong
from what I've seen
you know
yeah and like I said it's not saying it
couldn't happen I'm just saying that it
would probably be really unusual Prime
Times between like like I said 12 13 to
like 15 16.
16 might even be too old
um you might be more mentally sorted out
by then yeah you're over the hill yeah
as far as that you want it to be in
transition puberty basically basically
is what you're talking about
you want that
it's when it's going to be real [ __ ]
strong and explosive and it won't last
for long
a couple weeks couple months Maybe
very rarely a year
I think I think Enfield lasted the
longest and that might have been 18
months I think it was 18 months 18
months yeah
which yeah but and that's unusual
unusual this case is constant activity
this case it seemed like it lasted well
I think the the investigators got there
at six months and it didn't last longer
much longer than that because they were
there investigating and then it just
stopped suddenly like while they were
there based on what I saw and everything
that I've read that says yeah that's
real that that's like mine
they're short duration a month maybe two
my you know that that's about how long
it lasts yeah I mean your [ __ ] was what
like [ __ ] two weeks or something like
that yeah about that I think it was like
a two-week period yeah and I was [ __ ]
happy when it was over and I was worried
if it was going to come back
you know which it did eventually but
nowhere near the intensity and and the
the effects changed you know the
phenomenon changes over time it matures
with you but it's not like it was you
know but nothing's like it was when
you're at that age
you know that 12 to 15 that that air
that air that time span is [ __ ]
intense
when you're a kid if you remember at
least it was for me do you remember what
that was like
yeah but [ __ ] real in full color in
3D it's very yeah but it's I mean I
don't know I don't remember it being
that different but everybody's different
you know what I mean you're between man
and animal you know you're you're
minimal Manimal you're almost like that
show well you're human and animal kind
of at the same time it's like you're
having an Awakening you know you're
starting your Consciousness is starting
to
become that of a of a person if you ask
me what it feels like but you still kind
of have a bunch of animal instincts and
stuff it's a weird time I mean I
remember
that's the weird thing about it it's
like and I'm not like discounting other
people's
um you know experiences because
everybody's different like I said but I
didn't have like a huge transition
um between
pre-puberty and post-puberty you know
what I mean like it didn't seem like
like it seemed like an upheaval but not
like a huge like oh my God this is like
the worst thing ever like you know what
I mean that's I don't know I didn't
think it was bad but I uh I [ __ ] you
know I mean like it wasn't I didn't find
it like I didn't find it particularly
like over the top or different than for
me it was well yeah I'm sure it is for
some people I'm just saying like for me
it was kind of like just oh you know
what I mean but you know yeah it was
just it wasn't like a big for me it was
a big difference it wasn't a big
difference big difference like the me of
12
versus the me of 15 it was a totally
different person
you know it
healing the way you feel
looking through your eyes see what I'm
talking about your being it was totally
different
and it happened in a short period of
time
yes you gotta remember that like I I
kind of remember more and I don't know
maybe it was different from people like
looking at it from outside of me but um
I don't I remember it as more of like a
very very gradual transition I don't
remember this kind of because I know
some people just say like oh my God like
puberty all of a sudden I woke up and
everything was different yeah and it's
like and it seemed like very sudden but
I don't remember anything like that I
remember like a very very very very very
very very very slow gradient I don't
remember any kind of no not me
yeah I don't remember any kind of like
it was like a year
into like you know what I mean it was
like a year of [ __ ] slowly waking up
and becoming conscious of what the hell
was going on it was like that and it was
like starting all of a sudden you start
seeing everything in full color
you start you feel like you're here more
than you were before you know you're
interested I'm not really sure like I've
thought about this because I'm just like
whoa you're a girl though it's different
because I was being flooded with
testosterone you weren't
right and test is [ __ ] and then I
inject tests you put tests into a woman
they'll tell you the same thing if you
put enough of it in there like just talk
to those female to male transition
kids all right that they're doing now in
their teens
they say the [ __ ] test is [ __ ]
they just say it changes everything it
does if you're if you if you've been
biologically female
or you know when you're before puberty
you're kind of neuter in a way you're
not really one or the other you know
[ __ ] at a hormonal level you are
physically but not when it comes to
blood chemistry and it's a big change
especially I had a [ __ ] I had a
strong puberty real strong
yeah some people do you know I remember
knowing some people yeah I was like but
I did but the thing about it is that I
never have like strong like super strong
reactions to anything and I and I never
have done yeah like whatever it is like
whatever it's you know whether it's uh
medication or whether it's menopause or
whether it's anything people are talking
about oh my God it's the worst thing
ever and it's just kind of like meh
yeah you don't you're not you're not
what's called in the gym rat world
you're not a strong responder no I never
have been like I said to anything to
anything like sometimes like I'll have
some things that I'm just kind of like
oh okay but it's just like it's never
anything like oh my God like it's never
gonna happen compared to what I've taken
and what I look like now and this and
that know what I know I'm what's called
a hyper responder anything you give yeah
you might [ __ ] respond twice what a
normal person but see I always feel like
I always feel bad because I always feel
like you expect me to respond the same
way as you and I just don't and I'm just
like should I pretend yeah so you don't
feel anything no no this isn't happening
well I don't want to give you any more
you know what I mean but you should be
but she doesn't really respond to
anything no I don't she does but it's
very slight it's not a strong response
she still gains benefit from things it's
just not as much benefit as it should as
she should and I don't want to like push
it because she's female and I know the
data of what what a female can take and
what they can't take then you don't want
to push her into the male
into the male range of some of these
androgens I'm just well the thing about
it is that I've always but like I said
of anything to do with like biology
anything like whether it's drugs or
whether it's illness or anything like
that I'm always just kind of like like I
said you and this is from when I was a
little little kid I'd get sick you know
people I knew would get like horribly
horribly sick oh my God I was in bed for
two weeks I would get sick for like
three hours and I'd be like man I kind
of feel like [ __ ] and they'd be like Oh
I'm all right now you know what I mean
and I've been like that like pretty much
my entire life yeah everything is just
very Baseline I don't like stray too far
from the Baseline
um and I've always just been like that I
don't know if that's that's got to be
like a genetic or biological thing if
you take a girl and you start giving her
a bunch of tests to try to make her mail
what they report is something called
first of all a huge boost in aggression
and confidence they feel real good and
then the second thing that kicks in is
um something called a Clarity where you
have real and I get clarity a lot too
where you have real crystal clear
emotionless opinions on things where
you're becoming more kind of like
kind of like on the autistic scale I
guess you could say where you're just
real analytical and you're not really
well see I've I'm already like that so
maybe that's kind of why well you have a
lot of kind of like male features in
some ways too I don't know so maybe
that's why it doesn't really because I'm
like well I don't notice any difference
I've always thought like that you might
have already had a little bit of a
[ __ ] heightened test levels he might
have banned a little bit the only thing
that I could build actually you got
broad shoulders you might have already
kind of been a little bit more of a high
you you're funny she I've said this
before on the show she's the least
chick-like chick I've ever done
I'm not gonna say that she's like a dude
God please don't I want to say that
that's insulting
[Laughter]
women tend to be real emotional and
erratic and [ __ ]
um uh [ __ ] very difficult to deal
with she's actually the opposite she's
very steady and easy to deal with and
rational
um
very skilled at things and very
meticulous a lot of women aren't like
that she's also doesn't really have
female interests for the most part she's
not very fussy when it comes to like
things like makeup and grooming and like
you know like I do all that but I don't
really like girly [ __ ] and a lot is not
in a girl and I'm just a lot of times
like I'll put on makeup I'll fix my hair
and stuff but in a way like it's it
makes me very impatient you notice how
when I said grooming she talked about
herself
real chick like girls groom their
boyfriends they're constantly doing
things their hair and they want to look
into your ear and [ __ ] make sure
you're pulling [ __ ] Claires out of
this you want to do you know they want
they want to groom you too now when
women get that is weird that's not weird
no I'm just saying for me that's weird
yeah so you know I'm just like gross I
gotta do my own [ __ ] you do your own she
doesn't even have her you're an adult
most most what you see women changed
also as they grow older
the Baseline was you know women in their
20s and [ __ ] like they'll groom they
used to groom on you you know what I
mean ape ape female ape type [ __ ]
behaviors you know
um yeah making sure that you're [ __ ]
looking straight and your clothes are
good and your hair is good and you know
but she she's like she's like a dude
when it comes to that well no I'm my
mindset is
um you're an adult
I figured out how to leave the house
being clean and everything and so can
you I I you don't need a babysitter you
don't need somebody to fix you that's
not what it is figure your [ __ ] out
that's not why that's not what that's
that's where I come from that's not why
a lot of women are doing that though
it's no I know I'm just saying that's my
mindset it's just like if you can't
figure out like how to pluck your own
nose hairs and [ __ ] like that that's
your problem I'm not fixing that she's
misinterpreting what what the motion is
behind it usually what it is it's a
woman caring for you they're fussing and
trying to care but she's not like that
okay she's thinking in terms of hygiene
this you could be clean as [ __ ] doesn't
matter they're gonna be
especially when they're younger you know
and maybe that's growing up in Central
and South America I don't know uh might
be that [ __ ] North American women
they're they're not really raised to be
real affectionate they're raised to be
office workers most of them so they're
not really oriented towards
relationships not in the way Central and
South American women are
they think that's kind of beneath them
so that might be Paul I don't know about
that I just you know I've just always
been a more independent person so it's
not the first thing that I think it's
pretty well known that North American
women kind of look down on Homemakers
they don't they don't like that they
like professional women
for some reason they want to work there
they're told to to value that
because which is because which is stupid
because you're just they're just
throwing themselves into professions
that guys have hated for [ __ ]
centuries you know [ __ ] guys well I'm
a big advocate of do whatever you want
to do yeah if you want to stay home and
take care of kids then more power to you
yeah my mom was really into that
um she you know she loved kids she ran a
daycare she had four of us and [ __ ]
man I don't know how she did it but holy
crap and I think she always kind of
wanted me to be like that and I'm just
not like that my sister's not like that
either yeah
um dancing mothering yeah more of a
nurturing now I wouldn't say mother but
more of a nerd and I'm not well and the
weird thing about it is that I'm very
very mothery like toward Pookie yeah
like but
I've never I've never really liked
children
um you know I'm not a real
mom kind of person I'm just not I've
just I've never been like that I told my
mom when I was 15 or 16 years old I was
like and you know what I don't think I'm
ever gonna have kids and she said to me
when I was 15 or 16 oh you'll change
your mind older but I never did never
did
it's just it just wasn't my thing I
think it's hormones wasn't my thing
right hormones and I don't really
consider myself dude-like in a lot of
ways because in a lot of ways like dudes
piss me off like way more than women do
um and I find dudes a lot more
irrational
than women like um
I hang I I don't mind like I hang out
with dudes and I can talk to them about
stuff but
um in my experience like dudes are a lot
more irrational and like much harder to
deal with than women are
just in general like not always like it
you know everyone's different man they
got some psycho-ass women out there well
no
General
in very general terms
um I don't know like I I've never really
found I don't even know if I found like
anything between because man I've been
like some really cool dudes and some
really awesome women
um but you know I've met psychos of both
genders also uh so I don't really
discriminate I'm just like just be cool
I don't give a [ __ ] like what you know
you know what I mean I don't really like
put people into boxes like that just
kind of like be cool okay so we're done
with that case are you hungry yeah all
right
um
I'll get something to eat
yeah go ahead and shut that [ __ ] down
you're gonna shut that [ __ ] down you're
gonna shut the [ __ ] down I'm just giving
the [ __ ] word to shut it down yeah we
had a whole discussion if I tell her to
shut it down who shut it down me or her
and well it had it you know people said
well no that's it has to be you because
you always have to be in and then some
girls came to your defenses
just like you always have to be right
about everything you always have to be
in charge of everything and some girls
that came before came out because dudes
have very fragile Egos and they have to
feel like they're always and they always
have to feel like they're in charge and
that they're always talking about
no there is not well and the fact that
you got really defensive about it makes
me know
an outmoded wave oh is it six [ __ ]
trying to try to explain the way dudes
do things yeah this is not really no man
look I've had the high progesterone and
the [ __ ] the high progesterone
[ __ ] female [ __ ] uh biochemistry
[ __ ] when you're on shred you know
you'd be crying Cry Cry Baby [ __ ]
sentimental all right and had that whole
thing and all you'd be insecure on tread
that's not that's not a male feeling
that's it's a female feeling feeling
really you know being all insecure on
that and what it is is you're on when
you're on Trend being being [ __ ] like
you projecting that oh well you're
insecure no no no no no no no no no I'm
gonna tell you right now like the
difference between
I don't you know I don't know how close
that [ __ ] like approximated because some
of the stuff you described I'm like yeah
that sounds like being the woman all the
time and that's pretty much but just be
a Superman and Super [ __ ] at the same
time but see the thing about it is that
when women feel insecure yeah they turn
the insecurity inwards when men feel
insecure they turn it outwards like
somebody else is causing that
um in general not everybody like I said
everybody's different but from what I
found like women are usually like oh
shit's [ __ ] up I I did that I you know
they blame themselves whereas a man is
like oh shit's [ __ ] up somebody else
did that [ __ ] it wasn't me so that's
very general like I said that's you know
not everybody's like that but that's
in general that's kind of what I found
men turn [ __ ] outwards all right Jin so
I'm gonna give that I'm gonna give the
[ __ ] uh the command of execution all
right go ahead on the counter I'll end
it when I want to end it okay
shut that [ __ ] down we're gonna be when
are we when are we gonna come back
Friday we're gonna do the sign track
show Friday oh I got [ __ ] I gotta make a
new intro for that too I haven't done
that yet I only just made the new intro
for this show like today so I'm sorry I
like the new intro I mean that came out
really nice I thought I was worried
about it because I was like oh my God
this is taking forever and I was just
like you know I'm not super good at like
video editing so I'm you know I'm very
like rudimentary but um I think it came
out good I think it came out good so
we'll see how the sidetracks one uh
comes out I gotta I gotta make that
tomorrow so uh yeah so we'll see you
guys Friday night thank you everybody
for dropping by thank you for your super
chats we love you guys and we will see
you again on Friday evening good night
foreign
[Music]